GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING FOR ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON STREAMLINING
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE TO BEGIN
WE DO HAVE DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
PANEL TESTIMONY TODAY WE WILL
ALLOW IN PERSON TESTIMONY WE
WILL ALSO ALLOW REMOTE TESTIMONY
AT THIS TIME THROUGH A TELEPHONE
NUMBER -- OVER THE PHONE AND WE
ARE WORKING -- THROUGH TECHNICAL
-- TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WITH
WEBEX BUT THAT WILL ALSO BE
AN OPTION AS SOON AS WE GET
IT UP AND GOING IN ADVANCE
OF THE HEARING EACH PANELIST
HAS BEEN PROVIDED NECESSARY
CONNECTIVITY INSTRUCTIONS SO
PLEASE NOTE THAT -- THAT TIME
MAY BE LIMITED FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD TO ENSURE THAT
THE COMMITTEE IS IT HAS ADEQUATE
TIME TO BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SO WITH
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS COME
SELECT COMMITTEE IS TO EXAMINE
THE CURRENT HURDLES THERE'S
SURVIVORS OF INTERPERSONAL
OR INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
FACE WHEN SEEKING HELP FROM
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BY REVIEWING HOW
SURVIVORS OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE OF SERVICE I BELIEVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN GAIN
IMPORTANT INSIGHT INTO THE WAYS
IN WHICH THE STATE'S CURRENT
LAWS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
AND ASCERTAIN WHETHER CHANGES
ARE NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
SURVIVORS RECEIVE THE BEST CARE
AND SUPPORT POSSIBLE THE FOCUS
OF TODAY'S HEARING IS TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF CHILD SEX AND
LABOR TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A FORM
OF MODERN DAY SLAVERY AND IS
AND IS THE EXPLOITATION OF
HUMAN BEINGS TO FORCE FRAUD
OR COERCION FOR THE PURPOSES
OF COMMERCIAL SEX OR FORCED
LABOR DUE TO ITS A PROXIMITY
TO BORDERS NUMBER OF PORTS
AND AIRPORTS CALIFORNIA IS A
HAVEN FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
PARTICULAR ONE SORT OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN CALIFORNIA
INVOLVED THE TRAFFICKING OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA IT HAS FALLEN
FAR BEHIND OTHER STATES IN
IDENTIFYING AND SERVING ITS
CHILD TRAFFICKING POPULATION
LIKE MANY OTHER STATES
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON SEX TRAFFICKING AND
DATA ON PREVALENCE AND INCIDENCE
ARE LIMITED AND OR FRAGMENTED
THIS SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING
WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
CHILD SEX AND LABOR TRAFFICKING
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE RISING
PREVALENCE DUE TO CULVERT
NINETEEN IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE
SURVIVOR INSIGHTS SS ARE
BILLABLE SERVICES AND AND AND
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND DISCUSS
STRATEGIES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE OUR GOAL
IS TO SHINE A SPOTLIGHT ON THE
PERSISTENT AND GROWING CRISIS OF
CHILD TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA
HEAR FROM SURVIVORS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND POLICY ADVOCATES
AND LEARN WHAT THE STATE CAN
DO TO IMPROVE THE WAYS THAT WE
SUPPORT VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
I BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE ARE TODAY
AND WHAT ISSUES EXIST IN THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE AND TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
FORWARD AND ADEQUATELY SUPPORT
AND HELPLESS SURVIVORS IN
OUR STATE I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING TODAY'S TESTIMONY AND
BEING FURTHER EDUCATED ON THE
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE CRISIS
AND WORKING WITH YOU ALL AS
YOU CONTINUE TO YOUR IMPORTANT
WORK -- THAT YOU DO EVERY DAY
ON FIGHTING THIS CRIME AND
WORKING TO PROTECT SURVIVORS
SO WITH THAT WE DO HAVE PANEL
EIGHT WHICH IS AN OVERVIEW OF
CHILD SEX AND LABOR TRAFFICKING
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE RISE OF
THE PREVALENCE DUE TO COVERT
NINETEEN SO I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE OUR FIRST PANEL TO THE
DINOSAUR IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
REMOTELY OVER THE PHONE JESSICA
PETERS PRINCIPAL OF THE SCHOOL
AND POLICY ANALYST LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE ALONG WITH
-- JESSICA ERIC BALL CHILDREN'S
SERVICES -- ADMINISTRATOR FOR
L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
THIS PANEL WILL GIVE US THAT
OVERVIEW ON CHILD SEX A LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE RISE OF BROTHERS TO
COVER NINETEEN AS WAS ALREADY
STATED MISS PETERS IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE YOU MAY BE KEPT
H. I'M GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR JUST COMPUTERS BUT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WE HAVE PREPARED
A POWER POINT PRESENTATION
FOR YOU I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE COPIES OF
THAT IF NOT WE CAN FOLLOW AT AND
YES WE DO HAVE COPIES OF IT
OKAY GREAT HEARTS AND THINGS
HOPEFULLY AND IT'S GRADING AND
EVERYTHING INTERNET SPEED AT
SO AND I DEFEATED HERE
-- I'LL BE PROVIDING A
REALLY HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW AS
WHITE AND SOME OF THIS CASE
HOW TRAFFICKING LINES AND
PROGRAMS ARE FROM A STATE LEVEL
AND AND AND PROVIDING OVERSEE
FOR YOU AS WELL IN SOME OF
THE TRENDS ABOUT RISKING IN
TERMS OF THE DATA IN TERMS
OF EARLY AND THEN I CAN PACK
-- AND SO ON E.
AS THE FIRST VIÇT AND THE
PRESENTATION I GUESS AT THAT
POINT AFTER THE TITLE DEED
-- IT'S JUST WORKING OUT WHY
IT AND IF YOU CONSIDER CHILD
TRAFFICKING AND LOOKING AT
OUR STATE STATUTORY DEFINITION
AND IT'S INTERESTING THAT
WE HAVE THAT CONNECTION OR
AND THE CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
SPECIFIC TO MINORS -- COMPARED
TO SEX TRAFFICKING AND
SOMEBODY COULD BE CHARGED --
MORE GENERALLY WHETHER THEY
WERE TRAFFICKING CAN YOU HEAR
ME I AM SORRY WE ARE GETTING
I AM ON THE WEBEX
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT AND
SO THANKS TRAFFICKING
FOR MINORS AND
WE ARE GETTING THERE IN
EIGHTEEN AT BATS YEAH
I CULTURE AS STATUTORY CODE
SECTION FOR ACTION AND
IF THEY THINK THE LOOKING ASK
IF THERE'S AGGREGATING FACTOR
CARLINI INDUCING PLEADING OR
INTENDING TO PRESENT USED OR
TO ENGAGE IN A COMMERCIAL ACT
ON IN TERMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING
THERE COULD YOU LEAVE LABOR
TRAFFICKING AND CLOSE ACTION
FOR TRAFFICKING FOR LABEL
LABOR PURPOSES I DON'T WANT
AND THIS IS AT
ARE VIOLATING THE PERSONAL
LIBERTY AND ANOTHER FIFTY
INTENSELY OBTAIN FORCED LABOR
AND YET NOT TO THINK TO CHILD
TRAFFICKING I'M READING
THE NEXT BY THERE IS
A PAGE TURNER THAT WE HAVE
HERE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
HAVE WHO ARE CAL TRAFFICKING
EXTENDS IN CALIFORNIA
-- AND OVER ALL OF BASED
ON DATA FROM THE NATIONAL
HUMAN TRAFFICKING HOTLINE
LOOKING JUST TO CALIFORNIA AND
AVERAGING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND IT YOU KNOW WHAT
OVER THREE QUARTERS OF THE
VICTIMS ARE FEMALE AND MAHLER
PROPORTION ARE MALE AND THEN
AS A VERY SMALL MINORITY OF
EXPENSES ARE EITHER I'M NOT
AGAIN I'M FINE WITH EITHER THE
GENDERS OR IT WAS NOT REPORTED
AND IT'S NOT AVAILABLE FOR
AND THEN NEXT FIGHT IN THE
PRESENTATION WE LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ON CALIFORNIA CAL
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AROUND
RACE AND ETHNICITY I'M AGAIN
THAT THIS COMING FROM THE
NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE DATA LOOKING AT AVERAGE
OVER THE LAST FOUR OR FIVE
YEARS AND AND
IN THIS STATE I HAD TWO THIRDS
OF -- THAT THE RACE OR
ETHNICITY OF THE VICTIM IS JUST
NOT REPORTED OR NOT COLLECTING
MEDIA IS BEING COLLECTED WHEN
VICTIMS CALLING AND OR MAYBE
OTHER PEOPLE CALLING WITH TIPS
OR INFORMATION -- AND THEN
IT'S COMPILED TOGETHER TO GET
AN ESTIMATE OF THE NUMBER OF
VICTIMS AND THEIR DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION SH SO OFTEN TIMES
THAT THE PERMISSION IT'S NOT
COLLECT I DON'T MAKE THAT
CHALLENGING TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THE NAY CAMP OUT OF TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE IN THE STATE HOWEVER
WHEN IT IS REPORTED AND WE
SEE THAT CHILDREN OF COLOR
EIGHTEEN AFTER THE MAJORITY AS
AND SOMEWHAT DISPROPORTIONATE TO
HOW FEET DIFFERENT RACE RACE AND
ETHNICITY GROUPS LINE APPLE WITH
THE STATE'S OVERALL POPULATION
I HAVE SEEN CAN EAT THIRTY ONE
PERCENT OR LATINO OR LATINA
WE NEED TO PERCENT VICTIMS ARE
BLACK AND TWENTY ONE PERCENT
OF VICTIMS ARE BY EACH OUT
WITH EITHER RACE AND ETHNICITY
GROUPS REPRESENTING SMALLER
THANK YOU TELL ME
THE NEXT SIDE AND DAY
THEY SEEM DAVIS FIRST TIME THAT
THE NATIONAL TRAFFICKING HOTLINE
LOOKS AT THE
I THINK FANS AND AND
AGAIN I THOUGHT OF IT
UNDER REPORTING ISSUE WHERE
THAT VICTIM I INDICATE
S. BANKS DID NOT HAVE A
REPORTING THAT IS TO SHEPHERD
INTEGRATION STATUS I DON'T
HOWEVER OF THE TWENTY TWO
PERCENT WHERE THE INFORMATION
WAS REPORTED SHE WE CAN SEE
THAT SIXTY PERCENT WEREN'T
YOU ASK THE DEFENSE OR A
LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENT FIFTY
THREE AND FORTY PERCENT WERE
CITIZENS OF OTHER COUNTRIES
AND EARLY HIGH NUMBER
IT WAS THAT ARE
ENACTED BY I'M IN THIS
THEME DAVID NAME SCHOOL
I EXTENT THAT WERE LOOKING
OUT OVER THIS FIVE YEAR TIME
PERIODS I HAD THE INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED ON THE EXTENT TO
WHICH I VICTIMS HAVE CERTAIN
RISK FACTORS OR COMICAL HER
ABILITIES AND SO TWENTY PERCENT
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO CAN
YOU MISTER YES YES PLEASE
AS THOUGH IT IN EVEN IF THAT
TWENTY PER CENT WERE RUNAWAY OR
HOMELESS AND SEVENTEEN PERCENT
YOU CAN CONTINUE
I LOVE THEM ALL OF THEM
COULD HAVE BEEN ENACT TWENTY
PERCENT THAT WILL RUN AWAY
-- BUT THESE ARE JUST
LOOKING AT SOME OF THESE
COMMON VULNERABILITIES I'M
ELEVEN PERCENT OF VICTIMS
HAVE EXPERIENCED A RECENT
MIGRATION OR RELOCATION
ALL HEALTH CONCERNS EXPRESSED
HAD EXPERIENCE PRIOR SEXUAL
ABUSE OR VIOLENCE AND SIX
PERCENT HAVE ACCEPTANCE HE'S
CONCERNED AND SO THOSE ARE
JUST -- AN INTERESTING BROWN
ABILITIES TO KEEP IN MIND
AS YOU HEAR FROM YOUR OTHER
CALIPHATE OR ABOUT WHAT THAT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SERVICE
THE FIRE AND AND WE START
REACHING OUT TO THESE VICTIMS
THE NEXT BY AND WE WERE ASKED
TO GARY SPENDING IT AT MY
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING I'M
CAN PURCHASE TILED LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AND STILL
LOOKING ACCOUNTS EXTRACTING
TRAFFICKING I'M THE MAJORITY OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE TRAFFICKED ARE
TRAFFICKED FIRST TASK AND
AND ALL OF THE SEX TRAFFICKING
ACT AND -- ROUGHLY NINETY
PERCENT OF THEM WERE FEMALE
PREDOMINANTLY FEMALE AND ONLY
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT OF THE FACT
AND EATING AT WORK TRAFFIC TO
WITH AND I DON'T I'M AND
NINE PERCENT OF THEM WERE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES AND IT'S
ASSEMBLY DIFFERENTLY WHEN WE
LOOK AT CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS OVER HALF OF THE VICTIMS
WERE MALE AND AND SO
THAT'S A PRETTY BIG DIFFERENCE
THERE I'M THIRTY PERCENT OF
THE VICTIMS WERE TRAFFICKED
ARE SOMEWHAT MORE LIKELY TO BE
TRAFFICKED WITH AN ADULT AND
THEN -- ROUGHLY HALF
OF THE FACT THAT WERE CITIZENS
OF EITHER COUNTRY I'M SO
I'M A PRETTY BIG DIFFERENCE
FOR THE SEX TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
TEND TO BE MORE FEMALE AND ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE YOU ACCESS
AND OR PERMANENT LEGAL RESIDENTS
AND LABOR TRAFFICKING THAT
SOUNDS CUTE MORE AND MORE
PREDOMINANTLY MALE ARCHITECTS
TO TRAFFIC TO WARRANT MORE SO
WITH AN ADULT I'M AND MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO BE I'M NOT A U. S.
IN ADDITION ON IN THIS
PARTICULAR DATA SET THAT WE
LOOK AT ROUGHLY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE VICTIMS WERE REPORTEDLY
TRAFFICKED FOR BOTH TAX AND
LABOR ON IN TERMS OF THEIR
COMPARISON AND INTERACTION
BETWEEN THESE TWO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT CHILDREN
THAT ARE TRAFFICKED FOR LABOUR
MIGHT ALSO BE MORE VULNERABLE
TO SEXUAL ABUSE EVEN AFTER
NOT BEING -- COMMERCIAL THE
TRAFFICKED OR EXPLOITED FOR
THOSE PURPOSES JUST CERTAINLY
ANY CHILD WHO'S BEING TRAFFICKED
IS IN A VERY VULNERABLE
SITUATION TO HAVE OTHER
SHE HI WE WERE ASKED
THE PENALTIES FOR CHILD
TRAFFICKING WHAT ARE THE
WAYS IN WHICH THE STATE HOLD
PERPETRATORS AT THIS CRANE SO
ON AND SO WHEN WE LOOK
AT X. TRAFFICKING
WORK HE SAID INVOLVES
AGGREGATING AGGRAVATING FACTORS
NEED PENALTY IS FIFTEEN YEARS
TO LIFE IN STATE PRISON AND
A FINE OF UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SHORT
CALTEX TRACKING WITHOUT THOSE
AGGRAVATING FACTORS SUCH AS LIKE
COERCION THE VIOLENCE
AND AS WELL AS FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING THE PANELS
I STATE PRISON
I'M AND I THINK THAT
ANOTHER CODE SECTION FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING -- THE SEX
TRAFFICKING THAT CAN BE USED
WHEN I TOLD HER TRAFFIC IT'S
ALSO POSSIBLE THAT SOMEBODY
COULD TRAFFIC SAID CHILDISHLY
CHARGED AND CONVICTED UNDER THIS
OTHER CODE SECTIONS THAT KERRY'S
BOMB WENT DIFFERENT PENALTIES
ABSOLUTELY S. THREE
HER NAME IS WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES HERE
BUT AND YOU CAN CONTINUE
ONE WAY TO PRESENT OKAY
THANK YOU FOR CONFIRMING IT YES
AND AND THAT
IF YOU CAN HANG
ON JUST ONE MINUTE
DO WE HAVE WEBEX SEVEN
RUNNING YES SAM HAS
HAS A WE HEARD YOU
OKAY YOU CAN GO AND CONTINUE
WITH PRESENTATION THEY'RE STILL
WORKING ON -- WEBEX ISSUES
AND I AM LOCKED OUT OF WHAT
NEXT BECAUSE THERE IS TOO
MUCH FEEDBACK I THINK THOUGH
I WILL JUST FINISH UP OKAY
-- SHRINE THE INTELLIGENCE
IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT THESE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES SO I'M IT'S
ALSO INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT
FOR THE STATE'S THREE STRIKES
BOB THIS IS NOT CONSIDERED A
CRIME THAT IS I'M STRAIGHT
SH I'M MOVING PIECE OF THE
PRESENTATION ARE LOOKING AT
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE MAJOR STATE
PROGRAM I FIRST HOW TO BEGIN
I DID STATE'S PRIMARY AND
VICTIM SERVICES PROGRAM IS
RUN BY THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD AND IT'S THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION PROGRAM
ON THIS IS A STATE PROGRAM
THAT ALSO SUPPORTED WEST I'M A
LOT OF FEDERAL DOLLARS SH AND
THIS IS A REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENTS
DIRECTLY TO VICTIMS FOR
POLITICAL SERVICES OR EXPENSES
I'M COMIN REIMBURSEMENTS CAN
INCLUDE INCOME OUR SUPPORT LINE
AND THAT'LL I'M CARE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE RELOCATION OR
SECURITY AND ONE
KEEPS CHANGING THIS PROGRAM
IF THAT INCOME OR SUPPORT LAST
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU BUT WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HEARING
SO TESTIMONY PLEASE GÓM
I CONTINUE WITH THE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AS
IN THE PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENT
IS NEWLY ELIGIBLE BEGINNING AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR
ACTOR AND CHAPTER IF I SEVENTY
FIVE OF TWENTY NINETEEN
AND DATES HI THIS IS I PROVIDED
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
ALSO IN SOME OF THAT CHURCH
LATER IN THE PRESENTATION I'M
IN TERMS AS BEING AND I'M NOW
COMPENSATION THAT BECOMES A
RECEIVING FITNESS PROGRAMS
I'M IN TERMS OF EITHER MAJOR
STATE PROGRAMS LIKE CHILD
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS -- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN ADDITION TO THEIR
PRIMARY MISSION ON DEALING
WITH STEEP RIGHT EMERGENCIES
ALSO READ THE NUMBER BACK
PROGRAMS INCLUDING PROGRAMS
TO HELP AND THE CLEANING
CHILD TRAFFICKING SHOULD I
TELL THEM I'M HAS -- I THINK
OVER ABOUT SEVENTY DIFFERENT
GRANT PROGRAMS ON IT AND
IT SOUNDS REAL I'VE THEM
IF IN FACT WE TIED TO
CHILD TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
THESE GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDING FUNDING TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
I JURISDICTIONS MANY OF
WHICH ARE IN SUCH AS YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM LATER YOUR HEARING
TODAY AND THAT THESE PROGRAMS
GENERALLY DON'T PROVIDE IT IS
THERE IS A PROGRAM THAT PROGRAM
FOR EARLY IDENTIFICATION OF
COMMERCIALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN
TRAINING PROGRAM ADVOCATE
PROGRAM HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIM
ASSISTANCE IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH VICTIMS
OF TRAFFICKING I'M A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR IMPROVING OUTCOMES
FOR TRANSITION EACH YEAR AND
CHILDREN TASK ORDERS AND
MINOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PROGRAM ON THESE PROGRAMS
ATTY ARE TEND TO BE ON
THE MUCH SMALLER AND MORE
BUT MANY OF THEM CAN HAVE
I'M LIVING NEXT H.
AND IN TERMS OF ADDITIONAL
AND HE STATE PROGRAM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
-- GRANTS TO ASSIST I CHILD
TRAFFICKING THAT AND THEY HAVE
A CHILD TRAFFICKING RESPONSE
UNIT AS WELL AS THE COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN
CHINESE OFTEN PROGRAM AND
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
ON YOUR AGENDA LATER TODAY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES I WILL GOING TO FIND
THANK YOU NOW LOOKING
ARE WRITING IT FLIGHT
NUMBER A LACK IN WE HAVE
SEEN ONLINE SURE IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO FOLLOW ALONG IN THE
HEARING AROUND LOOKING AT
THE TREND IN IRAQ AND PRESENT
INVENTION AT CALTEX OFFENDERS
THE BILL'S GOING BACK YOU IF
IT CLEAN THAT OUT KOSCHECK
I IS FOR
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
THOSE PEOPLE WHO TRAFFIC
CONTAINERS IF YOU HAVE BEEN
CHARGED OR CONVICTED UNDER THE
MORE GENERAL SEX TRAFFICKING
PROVISIONS THAT THESE NUMBERS
ARE NOT NECESSARILY PERFECT
BUT THAT THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE I'M IT'S INTERESTING
TO NOTE THAT BOTH IRAQ
AND PRISON ADMISSIONS HAVE BEEN
TRENDING DOWN SLIGHTLY --
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WHEN
WE LOOK AT PRISON THAT MISSION
WE THINK TO ACT IN TWENTY TWENTY
PLEASE ACTED IN THEATER BECAUSE
PRISONERS THERE IT TRANSFERRED
FROM COUNTY JAILS AND STATE
PRISONS WITH WHY THE DELAY
EATING -- TO TO CULTIVATE
AND SO WE EXPECTED TO
SEE SORT OF A ONE TIME
DROP BOX WHERE PEOPLE
ARE BEING TRANSFERRED AND
TRANSFERRED TO STATE COURT THEN
AND THEN WE WOULD HAVE EXPECTED
BACK TO REBOUNDED TWENTY TWENTY
BLANCHE I'M CAN LEAD YOU BACK
IN THE GAME BUT IT'S INTERESTING
TO NOTE THAT THE TREND IS
OUR TO WHAT WE SEE AND THE
NUMBER OF THE LAST AND WE'RE
NOT REALLY SEEING A LACK AND
SO -- YOU KNOW AS WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THE STATE OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS I'M IT
DOES APPEAR THAT THERE WAS
POSSIBLY JUST EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW
AND -- IN TWENTY TWENTY IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF ARRESTS
AND THE NUMBER OF ADMISSIONS
WHICH OBVIOUSLY FROM THAT
DATA WE CAN'T READ INTO WHY
THAT IS THE CASE -- AND IT
YOU KNOW IT COULD BE BECAUSE
B. AND AND NUMBER OF PEOPLE
COMMITTING THAT CRIME DECLINE
OR IT COULD JUST BE BECAUSE
THE WAY THAT CHILD TRAFFICKING
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING SHE
I WAS PEOPLE ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE ARRESTED I'M
AND THEY'RE FAR LESS LIKELY
AND I CAN DEFINITELY
PLEASE CONTINUE WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU YEAH AND
IT COULD BE THEY THEY YOU
KNOW THE CRIME HAPPENED ONCE
OR COULD JUST BE THAT THEY
WEREN'T LAST LIKELY TO BE
ARRESTED AND THEN CONVICTED AND
FIFTY AND
I'M NOT MOVING TO THE NEXT
BYE BYE NUMBER TWELVE I'M
NOT IN THE ACTING NEEDED
NUMBER AND EXPENSE AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HAVE TO DECLINE OUT
WE HAVE TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THE CHURCH BOB THIS IS AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THAT DATA FROM
THE NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE AT THAT SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S ENTERPRISE WE HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED TO SEVEN HUNDRED HOW
TRACKING THAT DOWN ACTIVATED
BY THIS PARTICULAR BRAND OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS --
THAT NUMBER WENT UP IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THEN DECLINE
AND SO IT'S INTERESTING WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS
OUT COMPARED TO THE LAST AND
AND THAT IT'S NOT QUITE
FOLLOWING THE SAME TREND
AND AND SO IT'LL BE REALLY
INTERESTING TO DATA FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS NOT AVAILABLE
YEAH IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE IF BACK FRIENDS BACKED
OUT NO WAY THAT HARASSED
IMPRISONED EMISSIONS HAVE OR
WHETHER THE TREND IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS ALNA
HAS SOME DIFFERENCES THERE IS
MAYBE SOMEWHAT MORE INDEPENDENT
IRAQ AND PRESENTATIONS OVERALL
I REALLY THINK
THAT YOU KNOW IF
YOU SEE THE TRANSMITTING
IN THE SAME DIRECTION
YOU WOULD HAVE A SENSE THAT OKAY
WERE CONTINUALLY I'M ARRESTING
AND PROSECUTING SUCCESSFULLY
ROUGHLY THE SAME NUMBER OF
ACTORS I THINK A PERSON OF
INTEREST SH I'M TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU CAN DEPEND LIVING
REALLY DIFFERENTLY THEN THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO REPLY TO QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHY HE THOUGHT THAT HE
THOUGHT WHAT IS GOING ON NOW
IS NOT HAVE GREAT DATA
OR DO WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
I'M IDENTIFYING AND ARRESTING
AND PROSECUTING OFFENDERS
SHE BY THIRTEEN
AND THEN GOING BACK TO THE
STATE AFFECT THEM COMPENSATION
PROGRAM AND PROVIDING
THAT RACKS REIMBURSED AND
SO AS YOU CAN THANK HER AND
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THIS
STATE HAS PROVIDED COMPENSATION
TO ROUGHLY SIXTEEN OF
CHILD TRAFFICKING ANNUALLY GOOD
ACTORS THAT YOU KNOW ROUGHLY
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS AFTER
I'M AND THEN IN THE RANGE
OF SORT OF FIFTY OFFENDERS
BEING PROSECUTED SO JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF SCALE
AND THEN MOVING TO THE NEXT
CHART YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S
BEEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
AND THE AMOUNT OF COMPENSATION
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED TO
CHILD TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
I'M BEING IN THE LOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN TOTAL
AND FOR THOSE ROUGHLY SIXTEEN
EXTENDED TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THEN INCREASING ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND AND THE REASON FOR THIS
CHANGE IS YOU PRETTY MUCH
ENTIRELY TO THE FACT THAT
I THESE VICTIMS ARE NOW ELIGIBLE
FOR INCOME AND SUPPORT BLOCK
-- REIMBURSEMENT AND SO
THAT'S BEEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE FOR THESE VICTIMS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
RECEIVE OPPOSITION PROGRAM
CASH NOW MOVING ON AND
-- AND WRAPPING UP HERE
WITH WHAT IMPACT ON
THE PANDEMIC I TELL TRAFFIC
AND THE UNITED NATIONS HAS PUT
OUT A REPORT ON GLOBAL LEVY
AFFECTS I'M CAL TRAFFICKING
AND WHAT THEY FOUND IS THAT
REALLY TRAFFIC PERSON HAVE TO DO
I THINK OUR SUPPORT
CREATING AS WELL AS THE METHODS
AND MEANS OF EXPLOITATION
THIS REPORT ALSO FOUND THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CHANGES
THAT'S INSANE I'M AND AT LEAST
TWENTY TWENTY AM AND INITIALLY
IT DOWN IF THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
AVAILABILITY OF SERVICES TO
EXPAND THROUGH NOT YOU
NOT BE ABLE TO ACCESS MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS MENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH APPOINTMENTS THINGS LIKE
THAT I'M AND EVEN POTENTIALLY
SERVICES THAT MIGHT HAVE HELPED
IDENTIFY AND THAT THEY WERE
AND HELP GET THEM OUT OF THE
TRAFFICKING SITUATION I'M
LOOKING AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND I'M TWENTY AS FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR AGREED TO CONSOLIDATE
THE STATE'S VICTIMS PROGRAMS
INTO IN YOUR DEPARTMENT OKAY
ONLY ON PROVIDING SERVICES TO
EXTENSIVE SHOULD INCLUDE CHILD
TRAFFICKING ON THE AND THE
GOAL WOULD BE TO INCREASE
SERVICE LEVELS AND IMPROVE
COORDINATION AND THEY SAID
THERE'S MANY PROGRAMS AT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THEY
NEED PROGRAM THE
SIMPLE CHECK IT OUT
AND SO I HAVE SEEN PROGRAMS
FOR CONSOLIDATED INTO THIS
NEW DEPARTMENT HOWEVER
BECAUSE MANY OF THE PROGRAM
OFFICERS ARE WORKING WITH
THE THIRD PERSON IN THE BAND
FIFTY RESPONDING TO COOK THE
PERFECT THE CONSOLIDATION OF
THESE PROGRAMS HAS NOW BEEN
I'M CLEAR AT THIS POINT
WHEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
OPPOSING THE SPECIFIC DETAILS
ABOUT CONSOLIDATION YEAH
WE DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND CONTINUE
TO I REQUEST INFORMATION
FROM THE MINISTRATION AS TO
WHEN THAT CONSOLIDATION WILL
OCCUR THE LAST FLIGHT HI
LIKE SIXTEEN OF THE PRESENTATION
RIGHT I'M AT THE THAT TIME
DEFENDING ARE WE
AND THE THING AND CONSOLIDATION
CAN REVIEW SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR
PROVIDERS MANY OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR VERY SMALL AND
HAVE DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENTS AND THERE'S SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONSOLIDATE
OR STREAMLINED THAT --
STREAMLINING ACT THAT'S THE
CORRECT ANSWER PROVIDERS ARE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS A
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS -- IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT CONSOLIDATING
THIS COULD INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THE STATE
THE AMOUNT THAT THE STATE BANS
ON CERTAIN ELIGIBLE VICTIM
SERVICES AND CAN HE
MATCHED BY THE FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND SO IT'S LIKELY THAT PEOPLE
LEAVING SOME FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND AND WE JUST PROVIDE OF
PROVING EIGHT
WHICH THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
PURSUING I DIE IN
THE END OF MY PRESENTATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MISS PETERS AND
WE WILL NOW GO TO ERIC BALL BUT
BEFORE EVERYTHING FALLS SPEAKS
I JUST WANNA ST ANYBODY ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINE PLEASE MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED
ON AND SO RIGHT NOW WE WILL
CALL ON ERIC BALL OF CHILDREN'S
SERVICES ADMINISTRATOR FOR
L. A. COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
HEARING BECAUSE PRINCE WELL
THE MANAGER WITH PARTIAL CENTRAL
DUPLICATION OF CHILDREN OR
SEASIDE PROGRAM WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES I SUPERVISE
BOARD SHOULD RISING UNITS
AND TO RUN AWAY UNITS WHO
PROVIDE CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS
WERE VICTIMS OF COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION -- THE
PRIVILEGE TO BE PART OF A
DISCUSSION AND THE TREMENDOUS
DEPARTED ON THIS PANEL
APARTMENTS MISSION IS TO PROMOTE
CHILD SAFETY AND WELLBEING
BUT PARTNER WITH COMMUNITY
OF STRENGTHENING FAMILIES --
KEEPING CHILDREN HOME WHENEVER
POSSIBLE AND CONNECT THEM
WITH STABLE LOVING HOMES AND
TIME TO THE AS THE PROTECTION
OF MINORS SEX TRAFFICKING
KNOWN AS COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED CHILDREN OR SEASICK
-- THE SERVICES WE PROVIDE
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED
TO OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
PROTOCOL AND FLAGGED INVOLVES
IDENTIFICATION BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH TRIGGERS A
JOINT TRAUMA INFORMED VICTIM
CENTERED RESPONSE AND VICTIMS
GETTING CONNECTED MEDIAN LEAKS
HE SAID ADVOCACY AND OR SURVIVOR
ADVOCATES IS THAT THESE SERVICES
ARE CORRECT RESPECT THE LIVES
OF CHILD SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
-- WE ALSO HAVE SPECIALIZED
SEES THAT UNITS LIKE I MENTIONED
WE HAVE FOUR UNITS THAT ARE
BASICALLY TRAINED IN CAESAR
AND GUANTANAMO INFORMED CARE
-- THEY ARE PASSIONATE WHAT
THEY DO THEY PUT EVERYTHING
THEY HAVE INTO THESE CHILDREN
SH BILLS THAT POWER OUR
PROGRAM FOR PARENTS WHO
HAVE KIDS BEEN IMPACTED BUT
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
-- DOWN HERE DALY CHAN WHO ALSO
DEVELOPED EIGHTY SPECIALIZED
DEDICATED CORPORAL CALLED TRAIN
COURT WORKS DIRECTLY WITH R.
C. SECOND BIG DROPS DRAIN THE
ACRONYM IS DEDICATION TO REST
AND TO UPHOLD IT ADVOCACY
AND MENTORING THIS IS A CORD
THAT WAS DOUBLE DESIGNS FOR
EVERYONE IN THE COURT ROLE
HE SEES A TRAINED ON TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AND ABLE TO
YOU KNOW PROVIDE YOUR KIDS
NEED ARE WE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO WELL WITH A WRAPAROUND
PARTNERS I FEEL CAPABLE
CLINICAL SERVICES WHICH IS
CALLED I HAVE SEEN YES THEY ALSO
HAVE FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
-- WE HAVE NON INTERVENTION
NONTRADITIONAL INTERVENTIONS
AS WELL TO SUPPORT OUR YOUTH
-- SUCH AS ART THERAPY ANIMAL
ASSISTED THERAPY LIKE A QUIEN
THERAPY AND WE ALSO PROVIDE YOGA
-- WHAT WE DO IN OUR DEDICATED
COURTROOM AS WE PROVIDE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS --
WHICH IS KIND OF A CYCLE SOCIALS
FOR EACH USER WITH THE OUTCOME
BEING AN ACTION PLAN THAT EACH
PERSON IN THE SMOKE DISCIPLINARY
TEAM WILL TAKE PART IN PART
-- AND PARTICIPATE IN THAT
CHILD CARE PLAN A WE ALSO
HAVE CHILD FRIENDLY TEAM CALL
RCMP CHILDERS THE FOCUS AND
THE CHILD DRIVES THE MEETING
SH WE HAVEN'T POWER MANY VETS
WORKSHOPS THAT AIM TO PROMOTE
WELL BEING THE SOCIAL PATIENTS
THE -- THESE EVENTS HAPPENED
FOUR TIMES PER YEAR IF NOT FOR
WHERE WE TAKE YOU THROUGH TWO
OUTINGS THEY WORK TOGETHER THEY
PLAY TOGETHER THEY LIVE TOGETHER
AND EASY THESE OUTINGS ARE
MEANT TO ESTABLISH RAPPORT
AND BUILD SELF THE STATE WITH
A POPULATION THAT WE SERVE
-- WE HAVE PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION CURRICULUM THAT
ARE FOCUSED TOWARDS KEEPING
YOU OUT OF THE LIFE SO TO
SPEAK INTERVENTION CURRICULUMS
WHEN THEY ARE ALL WAS MARCH
SIMPLIFICATION WE ALSO HAVE
WHAT WE CALL OUR VICTIMS
WITNESS TESTIMONY PROTOCOL WHICH
SUPERVISES IT HANDLES ALL YOU
WERE GOING INTO -- TESTIMONY
FOR TRIAL ON THEIR EXPLOITER
AND THIS IS A SUPPORT GROUP
PUT IN THE PLACE WHEN IT
GOES FROM THE BEGINNING OF
SURE -- INITIATIVES
NOW IS OUR LOCATE RECOVERY
SERVICES CHANGED -- THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT AND LA
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A
WHOLE USED OVER BILLS AGENCIES
THAT WILL DO LATE NIGHT
AND OVERNIGHT OVER TIME
FOR LOCATING AND --
TRYING TO FIND THESE KIDS
OUT ON THE STREETS --
BUT STILL PLEASE FOCUS ON
CARING FOR YOU IMPACTED BY
EXPLOITATION WE TEAM WITH
MULTIPLE COMMUNITY BASED
AGENCIES IN THAT PROCESS AS WELL
ARTICLES THE PART IS NEEDED WE
ALSO CONNECT YOU FOR FAMILIES
OF VARIOUS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE A
WIDE ARRAY OF SERVICES TO USE
-- NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE VICTIMS OF CRIME
AND ARE SAFE USE TOLLS WHICH
ARE ARE WE ARE -- RECREATION
CENTERS OUR FIRE STATIONS
POLICE STATIONS AND THINGS
OF THAT SORT YOU CAN WALK IN
AT ANY TIME TO GET HELP THERE
WHAT WE SEE WITH THE COLD THE
PANDEMIC -- IT HAS DEFINITELY
IMPACTED OF ALL OVER YOU WE SAW
MAYBE A SIX PERCENT INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF SEASICK
REFERRALS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AS COMPARED TO THE PRIOR YEARS
-- ALSO NOTICED ARE YOU THOUGHT
GREATER SENSE OF ISOLATION
DUE TO THE RESTRICTIONS OF
THE PANDEMIC -- INCLUDING
THE CLOSURE OF SCHOOLS IN THE
COUNTRY TO INCREASE ISOLATION
AND THE DESTRUCTION OF HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS SUCH AS WITH YOUR
TEACHER THAN THEIR PEERS --
I LOST A JOB DURING THE PANDEMIC
HAS REALLY STRUCK OUR TAPE
POPULATION TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
POPULATION A LEADING TO GREATER
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY OF COURSE
AND LIKELY TO PLEASE PLEASE USE
THAT A HIGHER RISK ENGAGE L.
SURVIVAL SEX AND THINGS OF THAT
SORT -- WE ALSO FEAR THAT
INCREASED PLACEMENT INSTABILITY
DUE TO COLDER CAUTIONS IT MAY
RESULT IN SOME RIGHT AWAY YOU
CONTESTED PONTIFICAL THE BEING
RETURNED TO THEIR PREVIOUS
PLACEMENTS IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE STAFF IN THE PLACE WITH
ANY OTHER USE OF THE PLACEMENT
AND THIS HAS BEEN A BIG FACTOR
IN SOME OF OUR ISSUES WE'VE
SEEN WITH THE GOAL TO PASS
-- OVERALL L. A. COUNTY WE'RE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBERS TO START REFERRAL
OVER THE YEARS AND IS PROBABLY
ATTRIBUTED TO ADD TO SOME
EXTENT TO INCREASE AWARENESS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND INCREASE
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY WHO THAT
QUESTION SEXUALLY EXPLOITED WE
NOW KNOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND
WE KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT --
THIS INCREASED AWARENESS MAY BE
THE RESULT OF EXTENSIVE TRAINING
EFFORTS -- THE EXPANSION OF OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS PROTOCOL AND
WILL DEVELOP IN THE PREVENTION
INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR YOUTH
AT RISK OF DISEASE THAT
-- WELL ANYBODY CAN BE A
VICTIM OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WE CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THOSE
MOST AT RISK UNLESS CERTAIN
SITUATIONS A CONDITION THAT
MAKES CERTAIN PEOPLE FAR MORE
WALL OTHERS AND JUST KIND OF
TOUCHED ON THAT EARLIER --
OUR DATA SHOWS THE MAJORITY
OF TRACKING THE BILL TO COME
TO OUR ATTENTION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR -- -- WE'VE ALSO SEEN
CERTAIN RISK FACTORS TO INCLUDE
RUNAWAY BEHAVIOR -- DIDN'T
DIFFICULTIES WITH FAMILIES OR
VIEWS IT ALL ALL THAT
LEAVE THAT MUCH MORE VULNERABLE
TO EMOTIONAL MANIPULATION BY THE
TRAFFICKERS AND THE EXPLOITERS
-- ECONOMIC V. BASIC NEEDS
MET NEED GOING UNMET
THAT CREED I'M GOING OPENING
FOR TRAFFICKERS ALSO OFFER
SOLUTIONS TO COERCE YOUNG PEOPLE
INTO DOING THINGS THAT THEY
NORMALLY WOULDN'T DO --
PEOPLE STRUGGLE WITH ADDICTIONS
OF COURSE AND THEY CAN BE LURED
INTO TRAFFICKING BY DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL -- EITHER GET A BUZZ
LBGT Q. PLUS MAYBE
FEEL MARGINALIZED AND REJECTED
BY THEIR FAMILIES PEERS A
COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE MUCH MORE
VULNERABLE TO EXPORTERS AS WELL
-- THE TRILOGY FACTORS ALWAYS
PLAYS A ROLE -- AND INVOLVED
WITH OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
-- FOR THE YOU THINK SHE'LL
CHILDREN WE SIR WE FOUND THE
FOLLOWING RESOURCES BECOME MOST
CRITICAL MASS ECONOMIC CONCRETE
SUPPORTS AND THAT'S MONETARY
YOU KNOW THESE KIDS ARE GETTING
OUT THEIR NAME THINKING THAT
YOU KNOW THEY CAN DO THIS AND
MAKE A BUNCH OF MONEY A LOT A
LOT OF TRACK THEIR POCKETS ARE
EMPTY AND EXPLORERS POCKETS OF
FULL AND THAT IS PROBLEMATIC
SO WE HAVE A PROGRAM TO CREATE
WHAT WE CALL RESTORATION
FUNDS WERE WE CAN KIND OF ALL
THAT SOME OF THAT BEHAVIOR
AND WE CAN KIND OF GIVE THEM
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
NEED -- HOUSING IS DEFINITELY
-- OUR TAKE POPULATION AS I
SPOKE OF EARLIER I TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH OF THEIR HAVING
A VERY DIFFICULT TIME --
BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES
AND AND FIVE STABLE HOUSING
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
ALWAYS A PROBLEM AND RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THERE IS
THE SECOND FORMED ARE ALWAYS
A PROBLEM AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE WORKING ON AS A
DEPARTMENT -- DIAGNOSIS
TREATMENTS WILL ALWAYS BE A
PROBLEM AS WELL -- PSYCHOLOGICAL
AND PSYCHIATRIC CHALLENGES
ARE SEEN IN THIS POPULATION
GREATER THAN ANY OTHER SO WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD ON THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE WHO ARE APPROACH TO
SUPPORT VICTIMS -- INCLUDING
EXPANDING THE BEST PRACTICE
APPROACH WITH THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION -- WHO ARE
WORKING THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE COMMUNITIES OF STAKEHOLDERS
WILL CONTINUE DESCRIBER VENTURE
OUT OF THE STORE WITH PREVENTION
EDUCATION AND SERVICES SO ON
BEHALF OF THE P. DEPARTMENT
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
KIND OF CONVEY OUR APPRECIATION
BRING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO THE FOREFRONT AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH -- ERIC BALL
FOR YOUR FEDERAL TESTIMONY --
FOR THE SECOND TIME I WON'T ASK
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW HOWEVER I
DO WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE FOLLOW UP --
FROM FROM BOTH THE PRESENTERS
JESSICA PETERS AN ERRANT BALL
-- BUT ESPECIALLY FROM THE
L. A. -- -- OFFICE I THINK
WHAT'S MOST TROUBLING AND
ALARMING IS THE MISSING DATA
AND IS THIS SOMETHING THAT
IS A VOLUNTARY OR IS IT A
-- MANDATE A REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE THAT DATA AND IF IT'S
REQUIRED WHY IS IT NOT BEING
PROVIDED IF IT'S VOLUNTARY
WHY IS IT VOLUNTARY AND NOT
MANDATED SO -- IT JUST APPEARS
LIKE WE HAVE A LOT OF MISSING
DATA AND -- YOU'VE GOT UP AN
INCREDIBLE JOB FROM THE L. A.
O.'S OFFICE ESPECIALLY BEING
ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER THAT DATA
INTO SOME TYPE OF THE MESSAGE
AND NARRATIVE BUT -- STILL SHOWS
THE GAPS AND AND EMPTY SPACES
WHERE WE ARE MISSING A VERY
IMPORTANT DATA TO BE ABLE TO
ACT ON WITH THAT I I I AGAIN
WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKERS
MOST OF ALL FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
AND INFORMATIVE TESTIMONY I
DO WANT TO MOVE TO THE SECOND
PANEL AND -- WE DO HAVE --
ONE IN PERSON -- PRESENTER
AND THAT WOULD BE HERE TO
PLAY -- PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
RESTORATION DIVERSION SERVICES
SHE -- -- THAT WILL BE THE
FIRST PRESENTER OR SPEAKER I
BELIEVE ONLINE OR ON THE PHONE
LINE WE HAVE TO BE A -- THE
SELLER -- SELENA AND THAT IS
SURVIVOR ADVOCATE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
AS WELL AS JIMMY LOPEZ A
SURVIVOR ADVOCATE AS WELL
COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING -- THEY WILL BE OUR
-- LAST TWO PRESENTERS ON THIS
PARTICULAR PANEL BUT IF KIA IS
ON THE PHONE LINE OR NO I'M
SORRY YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON --
WHILE KIA IS SPEAKING IN PERSON
WE DO ASK THAT -- JIMMY LOPEZ
AND DO THE -- AS A LAY UP IF
YOU WILL MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL
WE CALL FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
KRCB WE OKAY
SO GOOD MORNING ARE STILL
MOURNING YEAH GOOD MORNING
OSELLA MY NAME IS Q. TO PLAY
I WAS TRAFFIC STARTING AT THE
AGE OF FIFTEEN -- I WAS BOUNCED
AROUND FROM SHELTER TO SHELTER
TO SHELTER AND I EVENTUALLY
GOT LUCKY ENOUGH AND GONE INTO
FOSTER CARE BEYOND A HOMELESS
TEENAGER GAVE ME A LEVEL OF
SURVIVAL NO PERSON SHOULD BE
EXPOSED TO ESPECIALLY A CHILD
BECAUSE I WAS TRAPPED I WAS
AUTOMATICALLY CONSIDERED A
TROUBLED TEEN I REALLY WASN'T A
BAD KID I JUST DIDN'T HAVE SOLID
PARENTAL FIGURES EVERY Q. ONCE
A FAMILY BUT BECAUSE I WAS
OLDER AND SEE SAID MOST FAMILIES
WERE OFF THE TABLE I WANT TO
FOR FOUR DIFFERENT GROUP HOMES
ONE FOSTER FAMILY AND THREE
TRANSITIONAL LIVING PLACES WHILE
I WAS IN FOSTER CARE IN GROUP
HOMES I WAS SURROUNDED BY OTHER
GIRLS THAT WERE ALSO IN THE
LINE WE ALL UNDERSTOOD THAT WE
WERE TOO YOUNG TO GET A JOB AND
WE HAVE TO MAKE OUR OWN MONEY
BECAUSE OUR ALLOWS WAS BARELY
ENOUGH TO BUY MILK FROM A DONALD
WE PAY FOR ALL CELL PHONES ARE
ONLY HERE EXTENSIONS CLOTHES
FOOD AND ANYTHING ELSE WE FELT
THAT WE NEEDED I ALWAYS THINK
THAT IF WE HAVE MORE LOANS WERE
OR IF I LOANS WAS REASONABLE OR
IF WE HAD NICER CLOTHES WOULD
WE HAVE TURNED OUT TO BE BETTER
KIDS GROUP HOMES ARE
CRAZY BECAUSE IT JUST DOESN'T
MANY FIGHTS THAT WERE HAPPENING
INSIDE THE HOUSE SOMETIMES IT
WAS SAFER TO BE OUTSIDE I
WAS THE MOST SUCCESSFUL IN A
FOSTER HOME FIRST TIME I HAD
A TWO PARENT HOUSEHOLD ALSO
KNOWN WAS ABUSING ME THEIR
WORDS THEY WERE THEY WERE KIND
AND STERN AND THEY PUSHED ME
TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL ON
TIME THE PROBLEM IS I COULDN'T
STAY THERE PASSED THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN I WANTED TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND TRIED MULTIPLE TIMES
IT BUT NOW I WAS LIVING IN THE
TRANSITIONAL LIVING LIVING PLACE
WITH NO JOB SKILLS AND I WENT
BACK TO WHAT I KNEW BEST THE
GAME SO WHEN I GOT APPROVED FOR
MY FIRST APARTMENT THROUGH THE
FIRST PLACE FOR YOU I WAS ABLE
TO GO TO WHILE TAKING GET MY
MOTORCYCLE TECHNICIANS LICENSE
NO NOT ACCOMPLI SOMETHING WAS
VERY REWARDING BUT BECAUSE
I LACKED LIFE SKILLS SUCH AS
FINANCIAL LITERACY ADVOCATE
PROPER HYGIENE MOST THINGS DATA
LAST LONG I ALSO HAD A LOT
OF ANXIETY WHICH CAME OUT AS
ANGER A LOT SO THE FIRST
TIME SOMEBODY SAYS SOMETHING
TO ME THAT WAS TRIGGERING A
COMPLETELY LOST IT I WENT BACK
TO THE LIFE MULTIPLE TIMES I
STAYED IN FOSTER CARE FROM THE
AGE OF FIFTEEN TO TWENTY ONE
MARCH TOURNEY AND SOCIAL WORKERS
PART FOUGHT HARD FOR ME TO GET
PLACED ON COUNTY AND RECEIVE
EIGHTY TWELVE BENEFITS AND
AFTER I AGED OUT CARE WAS NOT
EXISTING MAKING ME VULNERABLE
ENOUGH TO GO BACK TO THE GAME
AFTER ALMOST TEN YEARS OF
MY LIFE SPENT IN DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS OF BEING HOMELESS AND
VARIOUS DIFFERENT TRAFFICKERS
I WAS ABLE TO GET AWAY WORK ON
MYSELF LEARN TO BE THE PERSON
LEARN TO LOVE THE PERSON I
WAS NEVER GENUINELY LOVE AND
GAMER STRANDS OF FIGHT BACK
I NOW WORK IN TO READ SERVICES
AND NOT MUCH HAS CHANGED THE
FIRST POINT OF CONTACT FOR YOU
IS THE OLD ALREADY OVERWHELMED
SOCIAL WORKER OR CAREGIVER IF
A SOCIAL WORKER AND CARE GIVER
IS UNAWARE OF THE RESOURCES
IN THE COMMUNITY THE U. S.
SENATE INTO HOMELESSNESS OPEN
A PART OF A CLIENT'S SUCCESS IS
-- LIVED IN THE WHOLE PERSON AS
A SERVICE PROVIDING CARE GIVERS
WE THINK PRACTICAL WE THINK
ABOUT IT JUST IN THE PRACTICAL
NEEDS SUCH AS IMMEDIATE HOUSING
FOOD AND CLOTHING THE BASIC
NECESSITIES WHEN I USED THIS
EXPLOIT OR LABEL SEASIDE THOSE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS ALSO COME WITH
DRAMA TAKING CARE OF THE WHOLE
PERSON MEANS BUILDING A LIFE
SKILLS TEACHING THEM HEALTHY
COPING SKILLS BUILDING HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND ALSO ASSISTING
CLIENTS TO LIVE IN A WORLD
RISING ABOVE THEIR CHARM PART
OF STREAMLINING SERVICES IS
MAKING SURE THAT A CLIENT IS
CONNECTED TO ALL THE RESOURCES
POSSIBLE AND ACTUALLY RECEIVING
TANGIBLE RESOURCES IT IS
IMPORTANT TO TAKE UNCONVENTIONAL
APPROACHES AND ADDRESS EVERYONE
AS AN INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE NO
ONE TRAFFICKING SCENARIO IS
EXACTLY THE SAME AS THE NEXT
IN PEOPLE PROCESS TRAUMA
DIFFERENTLY COME OVER THE DOOR
EXPERIENCE DOOR UNDERSTANDING
OF BOTH MY LIVED EXPERIENCE
IN MY PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE
I WAS ABLE TO IDENTIFY SOME
SOLUTIONS TO STREAMLINE SERVICES
I HAVE LIVED THROUGH MOST OF
THE AGENCIES THAT WE SPEAK
HERE TODAY AND I GUARANTEE
YOU IT IS NOT ENOUGH THE FIRST
SOLUTION WOULD BE TO EDUCATE I
AM A FIRM BELIEVER THAT THERE
IS AND THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN
LEARN TOO MUCH EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE TRAINED ON
HOW TO ENGAGE WITH YOU WHETHER
TRAUMA FOR TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACH ANOTHER SOLUTION IS
CREATING MORE PLACEMENT OPTIONS
AND SOURCING I ALWAYS SAY IF
THERE'S AN ABANDONED BUILDING ON
EVERY CORNER WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH HOMELESSNESS SO
MANY OF OUR YOUTH ARE PUSHING
TO SEE SAID BECAUSE MANY OF
OUR YOUTH ARE HOMELESS OR DON'T
HAVE SOLID PLACEMENT CREATING
MORE SAFE SPACES THAT SHOULD
BETTER TRAUMA INFORMED THAT
WON'T KICK TO YOU THE -- JUST
FOR HAVING A TRAUMA RESPONSE IS
VERY CRUCIAL THE UNCONVENTIONAL
APPROACHES ULTIMATELY LED TO ME
GRADUATING ON TIME AND STARTED
MY JOURNEY OF COLLEGE I AM
NOW AN ENGINEER MAJOR PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AND I SIT ON TWO BOARDS
ONE OF THE BOARDS THAT I SIT
ON THE ADVISORY BOARD FOR THE
NATIONAL CENTER A FEW BLOCKS THE
CALIFORNIA -- WELL FOR YOU SEE
SAID ADVISORY TEAM ACTION ACTION
TEAM IS COMPOSED OF TEN LIVED
EXPERIENCE EXPERTS MEMBERS OF
THE ADVISORY BOARD ARE TASKED
WITH PROVIDING LEADERSHIP
CONSULTATION -- LEADERSHIP IN
CONSULTATION TO ACTION TEAM
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES COMMUNITY
BASED AGENCIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING STATE AND
LOCAL POLICIES FOR CHILDREN IN
YOU WHO ARE IMPACTED BY C. SAID
SURVIVORS SHOULD BE
INVOLVED EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY INCLUDING STRATEGIES
STRATEGIES RECOMMENDATIONS AND
IMPLEMENTATION BY -- BELIEVED
TO SURVIVORS LEADERS THAT
WE ARE CREATING MORE HARM BY
BY -- LEAD LIVES THESE ABOUT
EVERY LEADERS CREATING MORE
HOUSING OPTIONS IN EDUCATED
ON UNCONVENTIONAL APPROACHES
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT WE CAN
STREAMLINE SERVICES FOR VICTIMS
OF INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
STREAMLINING SERVICES MEAN
RESOURCES WHILE IN CARE BUT
ALSO WHEN AGING OUT OF CARE
AND PREVENTING THE GAPS ARE
ULTIMATELY CALLS US TO BE
VULNERABLE STREAMLINED SERVICES
IS THE COMPLETED PROCESS TO
BUILDING THE WHOLE PURPOSES NOT
JUST ON THE OUTSIDE BUT ON THE
INSIDE SURVIVORS ARE RESILIENT
STRONG AND HOPEFUL PEOPLE IT
IS IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO OF
LIVE SURVIVORS BY STREAMLINING
THESE SERVICES IN MAKING THIS
A THING NOT JUST HERE TODAY BUT
LET'S KEEP THIS GOING IT REALLY
MATTERS I'M NOT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR IMPACT
WITH TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM JIMMY LOPEZ IF YOU CAN --
YOU YOURSELF AND BEGIN TO SPEAK
ALL RIGHT YEAH GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AND -- THANK YOU
FOR EVEN THE FORTUNATE TO BE
HERE TODAY AND NOW TO
SHARE MY STORY AND AND
THE SITUATION I'M HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- MY NAME IS JIMMY
-- AND I WAS I AM SO
BY WERE LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
I'LL OKAY -- HUMAN TRAFFICKING
-- WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN
I WAS -- WELFARE TO
-- TO WORK I'M SORRY WHEN I
WAS FIFTEEN I WAS OFFERED TO
WORK HERE AND -- IN A FURNITURE
FACTORY HERE IN LOS ANGELES AND
-- GOLDBERG WE BEEN ABLE
TO HELP MY FAMILY AND --
FINANCIALLY SO I CAME --
HI -- MY DREAMS COME TRUE HE
DIDN'T AND THE UNITED STATES
AND --
I WOULD GET IT FOR TWO YEARS
-- DIFFERENTIAL FORGERY --
I WASN'T ONE AT THE BEGINNING
-- IT IS LIKE I WAS FINE BUT
-- THE ORDER THE PART TREAT HE
TOLD ME NOT TO BE OUT THERE THAT
LIKE A WEEK HE TOLD ME THAT I
WASN'T ABLE TO TALK TO ANYBODY
NOT BEING ABLE TO -- I'LL OR
EVEN TRYING TO -- --
SOMETHING AND THEN -- IT
PASSES TWO YEARS IN THERE
WERE IN THE -- I WORK I WAS
THERE I WASN'T ABLE TO GET
OUT SEEN THERE'S SOME
RIGHT OR GO OUT AND THEN
-- HE USED TO HIT ME --
AFTER TWO YEARS I WAS ABLE TO
ESCAPE AND RUN OUT OF THE PLACE
AND I ENDED UP IN OUR IN A
RESTAURANT -- SINKING FOR HELP
BECAUSE THEY USED TO TREAT ME
BADLY AND THEN -- I
AND THEY ARE WORKING WITH THESE
-- RESTAURANT IDEAS RESTAURANT
PLACE AND THEN -- I WAS THERE
WORKING OLD SMOOTHLY AND NICE
AND AFTER -- A COUPLE
MONTHS THAT THEY ORDERED HIS
HE TOLD ME ARE YOU WANT TO EARN
MORE MONEY SO YOU CAN HELP
YOUR FAMILY THE SAME ALMOST
BEING WHEN THEY'LL THEIR PLACE I
I WAS WORKING BEFORE AND THEN
-- ALL RIGHT AND THEN I
WENT IN THIS RESTAURANT AND
-- FOR ME TO WORK IN TRYING TO
DISTRACT FROM BACON FOR TWO
DIFFERENT PLACES AND ADDED ON
WHAT WAS WHAT WAS IN THE TRUCK
AND THEN BY THE TIME I WAS JUST
DELEON I WAS MINOR AND
I WAS ARRESTED AND IN
JAIL I WAS THERE FOR TWO YEARS
AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW IF --
I WAS CRIMINAL OVER A BIG TEN
THEY TOOK SO LONG TO IDENTIFY
IN THE HOUSE -- BIG THEN I WAS
-- SURVIVOR ALL OF OUR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING -- I'M VIEWS
HEY AND I DIDN'T HAVE ANYBODY
TO GET HELP OR SOMEBODY
WHO CAN HELP ME AND NOW
THEY ARE TURNING OF THE
APPOINTEE THERE ON THE COURT
HOUSE -- HE HELPED ME BECAUSE
I INTEND TO KILL MY CELL
WHILE ONCE I WAS WHEN I WAS IN
JAIL BECAUSE OF THE SITUATION
THOUGH THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO
OF FUNDS IN IT SAYING THERE
IS A PROCESS FOR IDENTIFYING
ME AND THEN I WAS GOING TO BE
PROSECUTED AND SENT TO JAIL AND
BAY FOR YOU KNOW THEY TRACK IT
WASN'T THE TRUCK IN THAT THAT
THEY FOUND IN THE TRUCK BECAUSE
THEY FOUND COCAINE IN THE TRUNK
WHILE I WAS DRIVING AND THEN --
THAT TOOK SO LONG THEY TOOK
SO LONG THIS IS THEMSELVES
ALONG THE JUDGE IT WAS ACTUALLY
JUDGING ME THE ASA CRIMINAL
AND DOES WHEN THEY ARE JOURNEY
AS THEIR FATHER COULD CALL
PASSED SCHOOL ISN'T ALWAYS AS
I WOULD BE IN TRAFFICKING WHICH
AND THEY HELP ME TO GET OUT
OF THAT SITUATION THEY HELP ME
TO -- I'M COULD I GET ALL THE
THIS SITUATION THEY HELP ME TO
BE -- -- TO UNDERSTAND
HERE THE LEGAL SITUATION
AND BEING LEGALLY UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING AND I GOT HELP --
BUT GETTING HOUSING AND BE
ABLE TO ATTEND POST IN GOING TO
SCHOOL ENROLLMENT TO SCHOOL AND
-- FIND A WORK
AND -- THAT WAS REALLY SAD
OR TO KNOW THAT THEIR GOVERNMENT
FAIL ON THE PART TO UNDERSTAND
THAT I WAS A BIG THING
AND NOT A CRIMINAL --
I AM FACING A LOT OF
PROBLEM I THINK IT IS --
ISSUE HAPPENED LIKE WHEN
I I TRIED TO APPLY TO JOBS
THEY I WAS REJECTED I WAS
NOT ABLE TO GET ANY --
ANY TYPE OF JOB BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WE WILL HEAR AND
THEY DO BACKGROUND CHECKS --
AND ANY COMPANY I WAS NOT A
SAID THE AND YOU THOUGHT IT
WAS SO HARD FOR ME TO -- TO
DEAL WITH WITH THEIR RECORD
BECAUSE I'LL I'LL WHEN I WENT
TO JAIL THEY PUT IT I WAS A
CRIMINAL AND KNOW THAT I WAS
TRAINED TO LOVE BEING GOOD --
-- WE DON'T FOLLOW THE RULES
-- I WASN'T ABLE TO DO THAT
AND I STRUGGLE TO FIND A JOB
I STRUGGLE TO FIND HOUSING I
STROLLER TO -- BELIEVE MY DATE
MY BASIC LIFE BECAUSE HE WAS
HARD EVEN THOUGH I WAS I'LL
END WITH THIS SITUATION I WAS
NOT ABLE TO NO -- --
FOR SOLUTIONS EVEN THOUGH I WAS
GETTING HELP BY CAST BECAUSE GOD
HAS HIS SON ON BROKER INDECISION
AND THEY OPEN THE HOUSE AND
THEY WERE I I WAS UNDER THEIR
SUPERVISION THEY PROVIDE ME --
SOCIAL WORKER WHERE SHE USED
TO WORK WE NEED TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AND GETTING HELP THEY NEED
THAT I NEED AND --
-- HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO CHANGE AND THIS IS
THIS THIS IS PAM HOW TO --
THREE BIG NAMES HOUSE BY
TWENTY FIVE BIG THAT'S WHERE
TERRORIST FLAGS ON HOW TO
IDENTIFY THE RED FLAGS AND --
NEED ABLE TO RECEIVE MORE
OR -- BEING PROGRAMS
WHERE I CAN OF
THE CLONE THE CLONE
BY MAKING MY DREAMS COME TRUE
RIGHT -- HAVING THE
JOB I WANT -- BEEN ABLE TO HELP
MY FAMILY OR HAVING ONE THEY
HAVE ENOUGH FAMILY BEEN THE
STAPLE -- HI GRANDDADDY BEING
ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL AND ALL
THIS STUFF BUT THERE IS A WILL
ONE RIGHT AND I THINK WE'LL WANT
TO ACHIEVE SOMETHING IN LIFE AND
NOBODY WANTS TO WORK THROUGH THE
SITUATION I WENT THROUGH AND --
WE I MEAN US ALSO BARBER ENHANCE
THAT AND WE NEED MORE PROGRAMS
MORE FARMS FOR SURVIVORS
TO KEEP TRYING THEIR LIVES
-- TO BRING --
EVEN ABLE TO GET A JOB TO
BEING -- TO BRING FOOD TO THE
TABLE TO THEIR HOUSES TO THEIR
FAMILIES SO PARTNER FAMILY IS
BECAUSE WHEN WE ARE ILLEGALLY
IT'S HARD TO FIND ALL THESE
OPPORTUNITIES WE MOVED BASICALLY
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPPORTUNITIES
AT ALL HERE AND THAT WAS WHY
I S. FOOD ALREADY SPEND UP TO
SAY SOMETHING BECAUSE ME AS A
YOUNG CHILD AND BECOMING TO
LIVE THIS EXPERIENCE AND NOT
KNOWING WHERE TO GO NEXT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN TOMORROW TO
ME -- I WAS LOCKED UP
IN MY -- FROM NINETEEN
-- SITUATION I EXPERIENCE
BY BEING HERE BY BEING LOCKED
UP IN UP FOR DENTURE PART
PROVIDE BEING LEFT OUT NEWS
IN TWO YEARS ON MY LIFE IN
JAIL AND THEN DOES SOMETHING
IT CANNOT HAPPEN AGAIN OR
KEEP -- KEEP HAPPENING AND
-- DOES ME AND I HOPE
EVERYONE ARE IN -- BUT
SHE AND I LEGAL BEAGLE
EFFORT TO CHANGE THE THIS IS
DONE AND BEING ABLE TO HELP
-- THE BIG TEN'S AND --
BIG TIME IN BECAUSE FAMILIES
AND -- THAT'S MY WORKS AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY AND BEING ABLE TO SHARE
MY STORY THANK YOU JIMMY LOPEZ
FOR YOUR MOVING TESTIMONY WE
WILL NOW GO TO ATTORNEY AT
SELENA -- WHO WILL SPEAK NEXT
HEY EVERYONE MY NAME IS
THAT I AM I'M A SURVIVOR
ADVOCATE CLASS COLLISION ON
YOUR SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
I WORK IS TO ESTABLISH
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN SURVIVORS
AND TRAFFICKING AND HELPING
THEM TO GET THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED I WORK WITH SURVIVORS AND
HOSPITALS IN THE COMMUNITY I
ALSO CONNECT THEM WITH PEOPLE
SERVICES AND SHELTER SERVICES
AND ANY OTHER EMERGENCY
ANY OTHER EMERGENCY RESOURCES
THEY NEED I ALSO
CONNECTED WITH I'M SORRY --
I ALSO CONNECTED WITH THE
LEGAL SERVICES SHELTERS AND ANY
EMERGENCY NEEDS ABC SIX SURVIVOR
IT JUST HAPPENED I WAS TRAFFIC
MY TRAFFICKER WAS MY MOTHER
I DIDN'T KNOW WHO OR WHAT TO
TURN CHIU CHAU ADDING YOUNG
AGE BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T ALL
SERVICES AVAILABLE AYE CHURCHILL
GANGS AND VIOLENCE I THINK
WAIT OF SELF PROTECTION I WAS
IN AND OUT OF FOSTER HOMES AND
GROUP HOMES I WAS INTRODUCED
TO DRUGS DURING MY TRAFFICKING
IN OVERTIME I BEGIN TO BECOME
HEAVY DRUG USER I HAVE CUTTING
INTO MANY DOMESTIC PARTNER
RELATIONSHIPS WHAT HELPED ME GET
OUT OF THE NIGHT AT THAT TIME
WAS DOMESTIC FUNDING PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES BUT THERE ONE NINE
FORTY SIX SURVIVORS AT THAT TIME
I WAS AFRAID AND HUMILIATED TO
TALK ABOUT MY SKELETONS IN MY
CLOSET FORTUNATELY THERE ARE
MORE OF THESE SERVICES NOW
THAN WHEN I NEEDED THEM BUT NOT
ENOUGH TO HELP OUR SURVIVORS
WE NEED HELP IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY CHILDREN HOUSING
AND SERVICES WE DO HAVE FOR
SURVIVORS NEARLY A HUNDRED
PERCENT -- IS DESIGNATED FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME SAYS GENDER
WOMEN AND GIRLS BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THE BOYS AND MEN
EXPERIENCE SEX TRAFFICKING WE DO
NOT HAVE THE SERVICES THAT MALE
SURVIVORS NEED TO OPT INTO BOYS
AND MEN COMMUNITY AREA WITHOUT
SUPPORT AND NOT PULLED INTO A
LYFT AREN'T WE ALSO DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW SERVICES FOR TRANS
WOMEN AND NON BINARY INDIVIDUALS
THERE IS AN URGENT NEED OF
THE SERVICE IT IS HOUSING
CASE MANAGERS SERVICES PARTIES
OPERATION COULD CHANGE SO MANY
LIVES FROM BEING STUCK IN A
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE SO MANY TIMES
WE'VE NOT SEEN A TRANS OR NON
BINARY CHILDREN WHO NEED HELP IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO SERVICES THEY ARE FORCED
TO TURN IT DANGEROUS PEOPLE
FOR SUPPORT TO STOP TRAFFICKING
WE NEED MORE FUNDING FOR
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES OUR CHILDREN
AND THE ADULTS THEY WILL BECOME
EVERY DAY I WORK TO CONNECT
SURVIVORS SHOULD RESPECT HOUSING
HOUSING ILLEGAL AND EVERY DAY
WE ARE FACED WITH A LACK OF
AVAILABLE RESOURCES IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE MUST WORK TOGETHER
TO ADVOCATE FOR MORE FUNDING TO
STOP TRAFFICKING ESTABLISHING
A COMMUNITY APPROACH TO
HELP SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THANK YOU EVERYONE
THANK YOU MISS ALLY ELSE ALSO
MISTER LOPEZ AND MR -- DO
DO PLAY -- FORGIVE ME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS
VERY VERY MOVING AND PASSION
AND -- YOU REALLY BRING OUT
SOME SOME POINTS THAT I THINK
ALONG WITH THE DATA -- HEARING
FROM YOU ALL -- AS AS
SURVIVORS -- AND AND VICTIMS
OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
WE COULD DO A BETTER JOB AT
ENGAGING AS WELL AS OUTRAGE
AND PROVIDING ASSISTANCE -- NOT
WAITING FOR VICTIMS TO COME TO
ASPEN OUT SEARCHING AND FINDING
THOSE VICTIMS -- WOULD BE
-- WOULD BE IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF NOT JUST STATED CALIFORNIA
BUT INDIVIDUAL LIVES SO AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR YOUR
FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL STYLE
STORIES AND INSIGHTFUL TESTIMONY
FOR PROVIDING YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS ISSUE I DO WANT TO MOVE
ON FOR THE SECOND TIME TO THE
NEXT -- PANEL THAT WE HAVE
AND WE HAVE WITH US -- REMOTELY
CHERYL TREADWELL BRANCH CHIEF
OF SAFETY PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION BRANCH
AND THE CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES DIVISION DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES WE
HAVE GINNI FITZ GERALD --
LCSW CLINICAL MANAGER CHILDREN'S
PROGRAMMING FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER WE HAVE DR PAMELA
DAVIS DIGNITY HEALTH WE
HAVE -- BUT JOHNSON DIRECTOR
OF PREVENTION AND LEARNING
COVENANT HOUSE OF CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH SARAH JOHNSTON
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COORDINATOR
PREVENTING AND ADDRESSING
CHILD TRAFFICKING CONSULTANT
TEAM KNOWN AS PACKED CHILD
AND FAMILY POLICY INSTITUTE
OF CALIFORNIA SO WE WILL START
WITH THE REMOTE PRESENTER CHERYL
TREADWELL AND THEN HAVE ALL OF
THE OTHERS THAT ARE IN PERSON
PLEASE COME ON UP I BELIEVE
WE HAVE FOUR CHAIRS HERE WILL
MAKE IT WORK AND -- IF YOU'LL
IF THE PRESENTERS VETERAN
PERSON COME ON UP TO THE TABLES
AND WE'LL START HEARING FROM
CHERYL TREADWELL AS WE SPEAK
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHERYL JOB WELL AS
STATED -- WITH THE DIVISION
OF FAMILY SERVICES AND
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES AND WE HAVE THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
STATE COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY
EXPLOITATION CHILDREN PROGRAMS
WHICH I WILL REFER TO IT
OKAY A LOT MY PRESENTATION ON
BEHALF OF MY DIRECT I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
EACH AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UPDATE YOU ON THE WORK WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE STATE THERE
ARE FORTY SEVEN POLICIES THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE STATE
STREET THAT PROGRAM WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WITH A BUDGETS LIKE
SEN THE CALLING EARLY FULLY
EXPLAINED THERE IS GOING YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALLOCATION
WHICH SOME COUNTIES RIGHT NOW
CURRENTLY SEEKING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- MULTI VEHICLE
REPAIR COUNTY DID NOT THINK
THAT THEY HAD A PREVALENCE OF
THIS POPULATION IN THEIR COPY
ONLY TO FIND OUT THE THINK
DIFFERENTLY ONLY TO FIND OUT
NOW THAT THEY ARE SPENT IN THE
NEED FOR FUNDING BECAUSE THEY
KNOW NOW DIFFERENTLY --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN -- SB SEVEN
NINETY FOUR WAS PASSED --
IT WAS PASSED IN RESPONSE TO
A FEDERAL LAW THAT WAS PASSED
AROUND FOR SEX TRAFFICKING
THE FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THAT
COUNTIES INCLUDING PROBATION
SOLIDIFIED DOCUMENTS AND
DETERMINE WHAT YOUR ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS POPULATION
-- COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT
OR ALLOCATED A MILLION DOLLARS
TO CONFORM TO THE MINISTRY OF
ACTIVITIES BUT NOT FOR DIRECT
SERVICES AND THEY ARE ONLY
LIMITED TO THOSE JUNE WENT
OUT JUST THAT ARE CURRENTLY
MEETING CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
WHAT OTHER COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT YOU KNOW FUNDING
FOR ALL FOR THE FUNDING
THING IS THE FUNDING FOR OUR
AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS FOR HIRING
A SPECIALIZED STAFF WILL BEGIN
TO CHANGE THOSE A PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT INCLUDING
SOME NONTRADITIONAL THERAPIES
ARE THEY SUPPLEMENT PLACEMENT
ARE THEY ALSO CONTRACT WITH
NEARLY BASED ORGANIZATION THAT
OFFERS A SPECIFIC SERVICES
-- CDSS HARLEY SUPPORT
-- TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE -- RESOURCES --
OR INDICATED COOPER EIGHT AND
WE ALSO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
A STATEWIDE EVALUATION WE
CURRENTLY FIND -- A STREAK
THAT CLAIMS RENT AND SERVICE
INTERSIGHT -- ONE IS LOCATED
IN SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY --
THAT BY THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND THE OTHER PILOT IS
IN SHOCK THE COUNTY THAT COVERS
THE NORTHERN REGION RURAL
AREA OF CALIFORNIA THE FOCUS
NEEDS POLITICS OR TO LOOK AT
HOW WE MIGHT LEARN AND ENHANCE
HOW WE PLACE YOU WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED EXPLOITATION AND I
CAN'T USED TO LOOK AT ELEVATOR
ENGINE TEMPLECOMBE BASED MODELS
OF CARE WE CURRENTLY PARTNER
AND CONTRACT WITH THE TOWN OF
FAMILY POLICY ALSO ON THIS
PADDLEFISH TO PROVIDE ALKENES
-- THEY HAVE A PROJECT CALLED
ADDRESSING PREVENTION AND
CHILD TRAFFICKING -- WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE INCLUDE FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE SO WE
CONTRACT WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW STATE
FACILITATE AN ADVISORY BOARD
THAT IS COMPRISED OF TWELVE
EXPERTS WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE
AND THE PROGRAMS THAT THE
BOARD IS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND COMPLICATIONS
IN THE STATE TO CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES AND THEIR PARTNERS --
WE ALSO SUPPORTED EXACT ACTION
TEAM WHICH IS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL THEY
HELP WITH IMPLEMENTING ACTIVITY
WHETHER D. GUIDANCE OR OTHER
BODIES -- WE CURRENTLY WORKING
ON THE SERIES RIGHT NOW THAT
IS BEING ISSUED AMONG VARIOUS
DISCIPLINES TO TALK ABOUT HARM
REDUCTION HARM REDUCTION IN
THE IN THE CONCEPT THAT IS
THIS IS A WIDE POSTED WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE CONSISTENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND LOOK
AT A DIFFERENT WAY IN TERMS OF
HOW WE WHO ARE -- VICTIMS
TO CHANGE EVERY COVER YEAH
-- WE HAVE STATEWIDE --
TRAINING TO SUPPORT -- FINALLY
WE HAVE A CONTRACT WITH UC
BERKELEY -- WHO IS CONDUCTING
AN EVALUATION OF OUR PROGRAM
TRANSACTION WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE IMPACT AND THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE SENIOR PROGRAMS THIS
EVALUATION STUDY WILL LOOK AT
OUTCOMES AND SYSTEMIC OUTCOMES
AND THE FINDINGS WE ALL SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE IN JUNE OF TWENTY
THREE -- AND LYFT
DATED EARLIER ANY BURKE SAID
THE LARGEST CHALLENGE THAT
WE ARE EXPERIENCING BUT CHAO
WILL FARE AGENCIES AND THEIR
PARTNERS AND HOW TO IDENTIFY
THE APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS FOR
YOU -- WE ARE ALSO MANDATED
IDENTIFIED IN THE RISK AND TO
SCREEN -- THERE SEEMS TO BE
HAVING INCONSISTENT SCREENING
TECHNIQUES ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH IS LED TO A DISCREPANCY
OF THAT OUR DATA COLLECTION
AND SO BASED ON THAT FEEDBACK
-- WE'RE WORKING TO BE VISIT
THE ADMINS DEFINITION DUE
TO THOSE CONCERNS SO THAT
WE CAN BE MORE CONSISTENT
ABOUT HOW WE DOCUMENTS
EXPERIENCE ACROSS THE STATE --
I WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH
THE -- THE MYSTERIES OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES TO LOOK AT THE TERM
OF A WALL -- WE WANT
TO DISTINGUISH THE DIFFERENCE
OF WHAT TRACK SEX TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE EXPERIENCING FROM
WHAT IS NORMALLY CONSIDERED
AN UNAPPROVED MOMENTARY LAPSE
IN THE PROBE PLACEMENT WE
HAVE USED THAT ARE LEADING THE
COUNTY OF THE STATE WITH UNKNOWN
INDIVIDUALS ABOUT ANY NOTICE
OR ATTEMPTED COMMUNICATION
WE'RE WORKING TO CLARIFY AND
REDEFINE HOW WE NEED A WALL
-- AND FINALLY WE HAVE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS EVEN WITH
THE STATE LEGISLATION -- SOME
OF THE AREAS AND HE WORKED
HARD TO BUILD OF OUR CHILDHOOD
FAMILY TEAMWORK WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE SORT OF RELYING AND
CERTAINLY LOOK AT THE WAY TO
BE MORE EFFICIENT AROUND OF
POINTING MULTI DISCIPLINARY
PARTNERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE WORK
THAT OUR DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
-- WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
WORK REQUIRES ALL SECTORS OF
THE COMMUNITY STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO BE HELPFUL AND WITH
RESOURCES AND LEVERAGE AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO FIND
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS TRAVEL FOR YOUR -- VERY
INFORMED TESTIMONY AND AS YOU
JUST HEARD THIS PARTICULAR
PANEL WILL EXPLORE THE AVAILABLE
SERVICES AND RESOURCES FOR
SURVIVORS AND VICTIMS OF
CHILD TRAFFICKING SO WITH THAT
NEXT UP IS JENNY FITZ GERALD
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- AND I I
JUST SET MY TIMER STYLE STATE
WITHIN TIME -- I
DO WANT TO THANK KIA JIMMY AND
DANNY AT FOR THEIR -- TESTIMONY
TODAY -- AND I WANT TO START BY
-- IS SAYING THAT IF
WE HAD SHRINK UNITED FEEL
THAT IT'S ALMOST IMPORTANCE
TO REALLY BE COMING TO THIS WORK
WITH A SURVIVOR CENTERED AND
THOMAS FORMS MENTALITY -- LIKE
MENTIONED -- THAT THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN COME FROM
THE OUTSIDE AND TRY TO SOLVE
WE NEED TO WORK WITH THOSE
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS AND
USE THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCES
TO INFORM OUR APPROACHES
-- AT SHRINK UNITED WE ARE A
VICTIM SERVING ORGANIZATION WE
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCACY
AND CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES TO
ALL ADULTS CHILDREN WHO'VE
BEEN IMPACTED BY INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE -- AND I WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK TO BORROW
THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY RESPONSE
PROGRAMS THAT WE WORK WITH -- SO
WE ARE A FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER
WE ARE ALSO A CHILD ADVOCACY
CENTER -- IN PARTNER WITH
DIGNITY HEALTH -- AND WE ARE
ALSO PART OF A SERVICE CENTER
-- AND WE SEE THAT BACK TO
MULTI DISCIPLINARY RESPONSE AS
KEYED TO RESPONDING TO
-- -- CHILD SEX AND LABOR
TRAFFICKING -- AND ALSO IN
TERMS OF PROVISION OF SERVICES
THROUGH OUR CHILD ADVOCACY
CENTER WE'RE ABLE TO FACILITATE
-- FORENSIC INTERVIEWS THAT
ARE CONDUCTED BY DIGNITY HEALTH
-- WHICH ALLOWS ALL PARTIES
WHO NEEDS TO HAVE INFORMATION
IN ORDER TO PURSUE A PROSECUTION
-- INCLUDING DCFS SO ALL PARTIES
WHO NEED THE INFORMATION OF
WHAT A SURVIVOR HAS EXPERIENCED
COME TOGETHER AND GET THAT
INFORMATION AT THE SAME TIME --
REALLY FROM A TRAUMA INFORMED A
CHILD CENTRED PERSPECTIVE --
AND AT THIS ABBOTT SEEM JUNCTURE
-- THE FOR THE CHILD TO THE
FAMILY ALL THE MEMBERS -- YOU
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THAT
EXPERIENCE ARE CONNECTED WITH
OUR ADVOCATES ARE CASE MANAGERS
KIND OF MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
-- SO MUCH OF WHAT WE'VE HEARD
TODAY REALLY CENTERS AROUND
PROSECUTION -- AND CENTERS BOTH
IN TERMS OF FUNDING FOR VICTIM
SERVICES -- ENDING FOR JUSTICE
-- AND WE HAVE SEEN THROUGH OUR
WORK WITH OUR MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM AND THE CHILD
ADVOCACY CENTER THE BENEFITS OF
THAT COLLABORATION IN TERMS OF
SEEKING JUSTICE FOR THE VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS THAT WE SERVE --
PARTICIPATING IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROCESS CAN BE VERY
OVERWHELMING IT CAN BE FURTHER
TRAUMATIZING TO THESE CHILDREN
AND THEIR FAMILIES -- AND THEY
CAN BE A BARRIER TO THEM BOTH
SEEKING JUSTICE AND ALSO KEEPING
CONNECTED WITH SERVICES --
AND BY BRINGING ALL THOSE
SERVICES INTO WHAT WE CALL A
ONE STOP SHOP -- YOU'RE
ABLE TO MINIMIZE TIME THAT
FURTHER DRAMATIZATION BUT ALSO
ENCOURAGE -- BACK CHILD CENTERED
APPROACH SO ARE ADVOCATES
ARE ABLE TO COLLABORATE WITH
PROSECUTORS WITH FORENSIC NURSES
SO THAT WE'RE PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT TRYING TO INFORM
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
PROCESS BOTH IN MITIGATING THE
IMPACTS OF THE PROCESS ON THE
CHILD IN THE FAMILY BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT THEY CAN THANK
YOU HAVE A COMBINED CAPACITY
CONTINUE PARTICIPATE -- WHAT
SHOULD BAN IS SUPPORTIVE OF
THEM CONTINUING TO RECEIVE
SERVICES AND RESOURCES --
AND SO THAT'S REALLY REALLY
WHERE -- OUR ENGINE AGENCY
LANDS -- WITH THIS QUESTION
IS CONTINUING TO FURTHER
THE PARTNERSHIP THAT ALREADY
EXIST -- BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADVOCACY SERVICES LAW
ENFORCEMENT MEDICAL SERVICES
PROSECUTION AND DCFS AND IF
WERE NOT RINGING ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE TOGETHER TO TACKLE
THIS ISSUE -- WE WILL NOT BE
SUCCESSFUL -- AND WE REALLY
RISK FURTHER -- INFLICTING
PAIN AND TRAUMA ON THE CHILDREN
WHO ARE YOU EXPERIENCED SO MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
TESTIMONY THIS PUTS GERALD
AND DR PAMELA DAVIS IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE YES THANK YOU
CHAIR COMMITTEE FOR INVITING
ME HERE I'M DR PAMELA DAVIS
I'M A FAMILY PHYSICIAN AND
EDUCATOR AT NORTHRIDGE HOSPITAL
AND WE'RE ALIGNED WITH DIGNITY
HEALTH COMMON SPIRIT AND ONE OF
THE GOALS OF DIGNITY HEALTH IS
TO DEAL WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OF ALL FORMS AND SO -- OUR
PROGRAM WAS STARTED IT'S
CALLED A MEDICAL SAFE HAVEN WAS
ACTUALLY STARTED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST ONE WAS IN
SACRAMENTO -- THE NEXT ONE WAS
IN REDDING AND NOW WE HAVE A
MEDICAL SAFE HAVEN CLINIC IN
NORTHRIDGE AND THEN SOON TO BE
ONE IN SAN LUIS OBISPO SOURCE
SPREADING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHAT A MEDICAL SAFE HAVEN
THIS IS A PLACE FOR SURVIVORS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO COME
AND GET TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
ALL OF OUR POSITIONS AND OUR
STAFF ARE EDUCATED IN TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE OUR PATIENTS
OFTEN THIS THEIR FIRST REGULAR
MEDICAL VISIT MANY OF THEM OF
ONLY SEEN MEDICAL CARE THROUGH
EMERGENCY ROOMS -- AND THEY COME
AND WE TRY TO PROVIDE WHATEVER
MEDICAL CARE THEY WANT THEY
NEED AND ALSO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES -- WE'RE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THEM INITIALLY IN A
VERY SOFTENED ENVIRONMENT LONG
VISITS AND THEN WE GRADUATE
THEM TO OUR REGULAR CLINIC SO
THEY CAN START TO SEE WHAT LIFE
IS LIKE AS THEY ARE COMING OUT
OF THE LIFE -- WE HAVE BOTH
SEX TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS AND LABOR TRAFFICKING
-- IT IS REALLY REWARDING FOR
US AS MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS TO
DEAL WITH THIS POPULATION IT
HAS WE JUST STARTED NORTHRIDGE
FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF
SO WE'RE GROWING -- AND
WE'RE HOPING TO GROW THEIR
SITES AND PROVIDE THIS REALLY
NEEDED SERVICE TO PEOPLE FROM
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THE
GREAT WORK THAT DIGNITY HEALTH
AND -- WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO
HELP IMPACT LIVES HIM BRING
THEM FROM THAT LIFE SO WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO --
JOHNSON HAVE A SEAT YES
HI -- I'M FROM COVENANT HOUSE
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO
GIVE A COUPLE STATISTICS TO
-- JUST SHOW WHERE COVENANT
HOUSE SENSE ON THIS ISSUE
-- THE NATIONAL ESTIMATES FOR
EXPLOITED YOUTH BETWEEN THIRTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN THE SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND NATIONALLY IN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE HOMELESS
OF THE HOMELESS ONE OUT OF FIVE
OF THEM WE KNOW IS A TRAFFICKING
VICTIM THAT MEANS ONLY ONE TO
THREE PERCENT ARE CONTACTED AND
ANYWAY BUYER SERVICES OR POLICE
IT'S CRITICAL IF WE'RE GOING
TO INTERRUPT THE PIPE LINE
BETWEEN HOMELESS YOUTH IN
TRAFFIC YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE BEDS
AND OPTIONS FOR YOUTH WHO ARE
NO LONGER SAFE IN THEIR HOMES
A VAST MAJORITY OF THEM IN MY
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN SHELTERS
FOR MANY YEARS ARRIVE AT
SHELTERS AND THEN WE STRUGGLE TO
FIND THE NEXT STEP THAT'S TRULY
STABILIZING FOR THEM EITHER
IN AN EFFORT TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES FIRST OR TO WORK WITH
CHILD WELFARE TO KEEP THEM
STABLE AND A PLACEMENT THERE
-- GOVERNMENT HOUSE SERVICE
OVER THREE THOUSAND HOMELESS
YOUTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE OVER A HUNDRED BEDS FOR
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLDS AND
WE HAVE TWENTY BEDS FOR THIRTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS THAT
SIMILAR SHELTERS AT COVENANT
HOUSE IS SUPPORTED IT'S LOCATED
IN OAKLAND AND DREAM CATCHER
DREAM CATCHERS SERVICE OVER
TWO HUNDRED HOMELESS YOUTH
YEAR A FIFTH OF THOSE ON
AVERAGE ARE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
CASES OF MINORS SPICER
SERVED IN DRUG SERVICES WITH
MINORS FOR MANY YEARS AND
-- THE AVERAGE COUNTRY AGES
FOURTEEN SERVICE SHELTER
BEDS FOR MINORS EVEN IF
ANYTHING MORE CRITICAL BECAUSE
THERE'S EVEN FEWER OF THEM
AND YOUR OPTIONS AFTER THEM
-- WE ALSO DO OUT OF REACH
WHEN YOU COME TO OUR SHELTERS
WE PRIDE MEDICAL LEGAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES SUPPORT
SERVICES -- LIFE SKILLS
SUPPORT WOULD WORK SUPPORT
WITHOUT APPOINTMENT AS WELL
AS PROVIDING STATEWIDE ALMOST
FIFTY TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BEDS
THAT'S IF YOU CUT THOSE FIRST
NUMBERS A DROP IN OUR
-- IN OUR POSSIBILITIES
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT MANY
COUNTERS MANY COUNTIES DON'T
EVEN HAVE SHELTERS FOR MINORS
M. THERE'S A SHOW OF MINORS IN
-- MANY COUNTIES THAT ARE BEING
EXPLOITED SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS
WITHOUT ANY SHELTER PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE AN INTERCEPTION
PARTICULARLY IN NORTHERN
COUNTERSPY HOME WHERE THE
MARIJUANA TRADE IS RAMPANT --
TRAFFICKING LOOKS DIFFERENT
IN RURAL COUNTIES AND URBAN
COUNTIES BUT IT DOESN'T SIX
-- SO GOVERNMENT HOUSE CONTINUES
OUR WORK AND WE ARE OPENING
MORE TRANSITIONAL BEDS THIS
YEAR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL SOMETHING CALIFORNIA
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
EFFORTS THAT YOU'RE MAKING
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF SELLING
GRAYSON THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND AND VERY
INSIGHTFUL AND ENLIGHTENING --
WITH THAT WE WILL WRAP UP THE
PANEL WITH OUR NEXT SPEAKER
SARAH JOHNSTON THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I'M SORRY JOHNSON WITH
THE PREVENTING AND ADDRESSING
CHILD TRAFFICKING PROJECT
OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA AND THE
TRUMP FAMILY POLICY INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA -- OTHERWISE ARE
PROJECTS THAT IS PACKED ALL ALL
USE THE ABBREVIATION FOR NEAR ON
BUT PACKED I CHERYL MENTIONED
EARLIER AT ITS CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE CAPACITY
BUILDING EFFORTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I SHALL MENTION
FORTY SEVEN OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
OPTED IN TO THE SB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE FUNDING -- THAT STARTED
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
-- AND SINCE THEN WE LOOK AT
THE CHILD WELFARE INDICATORS
PROJECTS THAT IS FUNDED THROUGH
CSS THREE C. BERKELEY AND THERE
HAS BEEN A OVER AT TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT
CHILD WELFARE HAS RECEIVED
-- AND THAT'S JUST THE DATA
THAT GETS TRACKED THROUGH WSTM
MASS -- AT THE HEART OF
PACKED IS HAVING AN INTEGRATED
RESPONSE TO BILLS CHILD SEX
AND LABOR TRAFFICKING AND WE
DO COMPLETELY RECOGNIZE A LOT
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT COME
AROUND IDENTIFICATION THE
CHERYL MENTIONED IN PARTICULAR
TO CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS -- ESPECIALLY AS
THERE IS NOT MANDATED REPORT
FOR CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS AT THIS TIME IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- IT DOES
FALL UNDER THE GLASS GENERAL
NEGLECT AND ABUSE BUT THERE'S
NO SPECIFIC REPORT FOR THAT
-- IN ADDITION A PLAYERS MADE
A RECENT STATEMENT REGARDING
THE GLOBAL HEALTH CRISIS WHICH
WE HAVEN'T SEEN AS SELF EVIDENT
AND IT SAYS TRAFFICKING IS A
DYNAMIC CRYING THAT WILL MORE
TO FIT THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THAT HAS CERTAINLY BEEN TRUE
WITH THE PANDEMIC AS AIR BALL
MENTIONED EARLIER LA COUNTY
DCFS NOTICES SIX PERCENT
INCREASE IN C. SECTOR FOR ALL
AS COMPARED TO DATA FROM PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC -- AND OTHERS
INCREASE FIVE HOSPITALS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
-- THERE IS A HUGE CONCERN FOR
YEARS HE SPENT HOURS ONLINE AND
UNSUPERVISED AROUND EXPOSURE
TO ONLINE PREDATORS THE STOP
SCHOOL SYSTEMS ALSO BEGIN
TO IMPLEMENT NOTIFICATION
PROBLEM PROGRAMS WITHIN THEIR
ONLINE PLATFORMS TO FACT
FLAG CERTAIN WORDS THAT WOULD
NEGATE CONCERN OR INVESTIGATION
AND MANY USERS REPORTED GREATER
STRESS AND ISOLATION DUE TO
THE RESTRICTIONS INCLUDING
CLOSING OF SCHOOLS THAT FORCED
YOU TO DOCTORS LEARN VIRTUALLY
AT HOME OR IN PLACEMENT
WITHOUT PROVIDERS REPORTED
SPIKES IN CALLS TO HOTLINES
FOR INCIDENCE OF INTERPERSONAL
VIOLENCE AND TRAFFICKING
WELL THE NATIONAL HOTLINE AND
-- SAY HOT LINES IN SERVICE
PROVIDERS IDENTIFIED INCREASING
NEEDS DURING THE PANDEMIC
AS WELL AS OFFICE THE
TRAFFICKING IN PERSONS REPORTED
THAT THERE IS AN INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ELIGIBILITY LETTERS THAT WERE
ISSUED IN CALIFORNIA AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR NATIONAL MINERS
WHEN WE WORK WITH CHILD A CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE WE HEAR PRETTY SIMILAR
THINGS ACROSS THE STATE AS
FAR AS NEEDS AND CHALLENGES
GO AS MENTIONED PLACEMENT
IS A HUGE CHALLENGE -- AND
THAT HAS INCREASING KOBE AND
DO YOU TO YOU ADD INSTABILITY
DELAYS AND DENIALS AND LACK
OF PLACEMENTS WERE HEIGHTENED
SPECIFICALLY FOR C. SACK YOU
OF -- FOR EXAMPLE YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO BE QUARANTINED AFTER
RUNAWAY EPISODES PROTECT STAFF
AGAINST TO PROTECT OTHERS
YOU'D BETTER AND PLACEMENTS --
AND IN ADDITION CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES REPORTED SYSTEM
SIGNIFICANT STAFFING IMPACTS AS
WE'VE ALL SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND BECAUSE OF THE
REDUCTION OF SERVICES AND --
THE THE STAFFING CHALLENGES AND
MANY MANY STAFF WERE FACED WITH
HAVING HIGHER CASELOADS -- AND
HAVING TO SERVE MANY USERS AT
ONCE AND WITH INCREASED BARRIERS
-- AS JENNY MENTIONED EARLIER
WE REALLY DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
COMMUNITY PREVENTION APPROACH
THAT STARTS EARLY THAT'S
COLLABORATIVE AND THAT'S
COMPREHENSIVE THAT HAS TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING BREEDS
OF EXPLOITATION AND KNOWLEDGE
IN THE SYSTEMS OF RACISM
XENOPHOBIA HOMOPHOBIA CLASSISM
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND SYSTEMS
THAT PEOPLE VULNERABILITIES
THAT TRAFFICKERS EXPLAINS
-- AND ALSO MUST ENGAGE THE
VOICES OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THAT PARTICIPATE IN --
BUILDING COMMUNITIES THAT PEROT
EQUITY AND REINVENTING SYSTEMS
AFTER TAX RATHER THAN RE HARM
A LOT OF THE EFFORTS AND IN
HALF OF ALL AROUND SUPPORTING
COUNTIES AND THEIR PREVENTION
EFFORTS AS WELL AS DEVELOPING
OUT SYSTEMS THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE YOUTH
THAT ARE ALREADY WITHIN THEIR
SYSTEMS AND THAT THEY CONTINUE
TO SEE ENTERING THE SYSTEM
IT REALLY TAKES A COMMUNITY
TO SUPPORT ONE SURVIVOR OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND AND THEIR
JOURNEY OF RECOVERY AND THERE'S
NO ONE PROVIDER THAT'S GOING TO
ME ALL OF THOSE NEEDS AS YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY FROM MANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS FROM SHELTER
SERVICES TO LEGAL SERVICES TO
ADVOCACY IN CASE MANAGEMENT
TO PHYSICAL HEALTH AND MEDICAL
TREATMENT AS WELL AS MENTAL
HEALTH THERE SO MANY NEEDS AMONG
SURVIVORS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THERE'S BEEN MANY THERE'S MANY
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE SURVIVORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING AND HELLO
YES AND AND AS WELL AS FEDERAL
FUNDING SOURCES THROUGH OF THE
SEA AND THROUGH HHS AND NASTY
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE ALLOCATION
THAT GOES DIRECTLY TO CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE BUT GAPS STILL EXIST
FOR VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING
INCLUDING IN SHORT AND LONG TERM
HOUSING AS WELL AS FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS DURING THE HEALING PROCESS
AND ADDITIONALLY CERTAIN AREAS
ACROSS THE STATE HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED AND PARTICULARLY
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
LACK OF ACCESS RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT SURVIVORS EVEN IF
THEY'RE IDENTIFIED IN THE DO
COME FORWARD THOSE RESOURCES
MAY NOT BE THERE THEY'RE
ALSO LACKS SERVICES AROUND
FAMILY AND CAREGIVER SUPPORTS
AND SELF FAMILIES THAT HAVE
YOUTH THAT ARE GOING THROUGH
TRAFFICKING SITUATIONS MAY
NOT HAVE THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED TO SUPPORT THEIR USE
AND TO SUPPORT THEIR CAT --
AND -- DIVERSE POPULATIONS
ARE OF PARTICULAR VULNERABILITY
FOR EXAMPLE L. G. B. T.
Q. I. A TWO AT TWO SPIRIT
PLUS AND INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS
USE IN CHILD FOREVER'S OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING -- ALL
ARE CONSIDERED VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO TRAFFICKING
THAT THERE'S A SEVERE
LACK OF RESOURCES FOR
-- IT BECOMES REALLY NEW ONES
WHEN WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
AS WELL AS I MENTIONED THEY
MAY FALL WITHIN THE PURVIEW
OF THE COLLECTION ABUSE BUT
THAT DOESN'T AUTOMATICALLY
INDICATE A MANDATED REPORTER
AND THEN THOSE YOU DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO -- THE RESOURCES
THAT COME THROUGH SYSTEMS
LIKE THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
LOOKING FORWARD WE HOPE THAT
-- CONTINUED AT CAPACITY
BUILDING CAN BE DONE AROUND AND
LOOKING AT SOCIETY'S BIAS SEES
AND AND TRYING TO YOU KNOW
CREATE SOME VISIBILITY FOR
GROUPS OF SURVIVORS AND WE
NEED TO SHIFT BACK THROUGH
EDUCATION -- AND WE NEED TO
SHIFT BACK THROUGH THE SPREAD
OF RESOURCES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
ALL GROUPS AND POPULATIONS TO
REVERSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU MISTER OBSERVATION
TESTIMONY AND AGAIN FOR TIME'S
SAKE I'M GOING TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS BUT I REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE ESPECIALLY THE PANELS
-- IN THIS PARTICULAR PANEL
TO -- REACH OUT TO MY OFFICE
COMMUNICATOR ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT YOU FACE DURING COLDER
NINETEEN AND RESOURCES BUT
ALSO WHAT RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
TO REALLY EXPAND AND IMPROVE
OUR EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THIS
VERY SERIOUS SUBJECT AND WHAT I
CONSIDER TO BE A CRISIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
TRAFFICKING OF OUR CHILDREN SO
PLEASE REACH OUT IN THAT AREA I
DO WANT TO BRING UP SOME THINGS
THAT STOOD OUT FROM THIS PANEL
AND -- MIST -- TREADWELL AND
STARTED OFF THE PANEL AND MAY I
ALLUDED TO THIS -- INFORMATION
ABOUT NOT JUST THE MISSING DATA
BUT TAKING DATA AND PUTTING
IT TOGETHER TO WORK ACTUALLY IS
IS A WORKABLE -- TOOL
IN OUR TOOLBOX SO IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT GOING AND GETTING A JUST
A BUNCH OF INFORMATION BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY GETTING INFORMATION
IN A CONSISTENT WAY TO WHERE
WE ACTUALLY GET THE MESSAGE THAT
WE NEED AND ARE ABLE TO CREATE
TOOLS FROM THAT DATA THAT IS
COLLECTED AND THEN ALSO WHAT
I WAS INSPIRED BY WHAT APPEARS
TO BE A THEME FROM ONE PANEL
TO ANOTHER AT LEAST ONE OF
THE THEMES AND THAT WAS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR AGENCIES
AND FOR DIFFERENT GROUPS TO BE
ABLE TO COLLABORATE AND BRING
THINGS TOGETHER WHICH LEADS
ME TO THE GOOD WORK OF DIGNITY
AND AND THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING AND WHAT I HOPE FOR IS
THAT -- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CATCHES THE ATTENTION OF ALL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
REALLY BE INTERESTED TO HEAR
IS THERE A CONCERN OF EFFORT
TO BE ABLE TO COLLABORATE --
BETWEEN HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY -- DIGNITY AS
AS -- AS GREAT OF A WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING -- YOUR RESOURCES
ARE LIMITED SO TO BE ABLE TO
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY DOING --
COLLECTING DATA IN A CONSISTENT
WAY BUT WE'RE PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE IN A CONSISTENT WAY AS
WELL THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE AND I WAS -- REALLY
-- -- SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD
SPEND KNOWN OR UNDERSTOOD BUT
-- I HAD MENTIONED IN A PREVIOUS
PANEL ABOUT BEING PROACTIVE
AND NOT WAITING FOR VICTIMS TO
COME OUT AND AND GET HELP BUT
ACTUALLY SEARCHING OUT THOSE
VICTIMS WHERE THEY ARE BECAUSE
WE KNOW AT LEAST IT MAY BE
AT A TOTAL -- IN A SCIENTIFIC
SENSE BUT WE KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF VICTIMS OUT THERE THAT
ARE NOT REPORTING THAT ARE NOT
COMING OUT AND AND SEEKING THE
HELP THAT THEY NEED BUT THEY
HOLD THEM FOR A LIFETIME AND
IT ALWAYS MANIFEST IN OTHER
WAYS AND LIFE SO WITH THAT I
-- I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY
INTERESTING THAT ONE OF THOSE
STARTING POINTS IS ACTUALLY
REACHING OUT TO HOMELESS YOUTH
FINDING THE HOMELESS YOUTH ON
THE STREETS AND THEM MAKING
SERVICES AVAILABLE AND TO
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY BEGAN TO
BUILD SOMETHING THEY'VE NEVER
EXPANSION FOR THAT STRESSED
AND THEIR LIFE AND TRUST HEELS
AND TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT IT
OPENS UP THINGS AS WELL MORE
THAN TO BE ABLE TO HEAL AND THE
OTHER THING THAT REALLY BROUGHT
A LOT OF CONCERN TO ME IS THAT
I THINK I'M HEARING A MESSAGE
THAT'S REALLY RESOUNDING AND
THAT IS IN MANY CASES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA REALLY
THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE TO DEAL
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN THIS CRISIS IS THROUGH OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ARE YOUTH
ARE ARE ARE USED JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND THAT HAS BECOME KIND OF
THE THE LANDING SPOT BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT WE STRUGGLE
YEAH AND AND AND RESOURCES
AND OTHER OTHER AREAS SO
IF IF THERE IS A FAMILY JUSTICE
CENTER OR THERE IS A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER OR OR THEY ARE CAUGHT
OUT ON THE STREETS AND HIT A
HOMELESS SITUATION AND THOSE
RESOURCES ARE LACKING OR THE
LACK OF EDUCATION TO WHATEVER
AGENCY IS FINDING THEM THEY
JUST END UP GETTING PUT INTO A
PIPELINE OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND THEN WE REALLY LOSE AT THAT
POINT SO WITH THAT I DO WANT
TO THANK THIS PANEL FOR YOUR
REALLY REALLY GREAT TESTIMONY
ALONG WITH THE OTHER PANELS
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT PANEL SO AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK MISTRETTA WELLNESS BUT
STROKES DR DAVIS MR JOHNSON
AND ALSO MISSED JOBS DONE FOR
YOUR WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING ON
BEHALF OF SURVIVORS OF CHILD
TRAFFICKING I WOULD ALSO LIKE
NOW TO INVITE OUR FINAL PANEL
TO THE DIASPORA ACTUALLY IN
THIS CASE REMOTELY IT WOULD
BE FEDERAL DOLLARS CHAIRMAN
OF LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
IT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE LEAVE
LACHAPELLE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF SURVIVAL -- SURVIVOR ADVOCACY
THE COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING KATE
WALKER BROWN SENIOR DIRECTOR
COLLABORATIVE RESPONSES TO
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
INITIATIVE THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND ALSO
-- INCLUDED IN THIS PANEL IS
LESLIE STAR HI MOM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA THIS PANEL
WILL EXPLORE THE STRATEGIES
RECOMMEND AND RECOMMENDATIONS
IN ORDER TO STREAMLINE
SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS AND
VICTIMS OF CHILD TRAFFICKING
WE WILL BEGIN WITH PEDROZA NOT
YES GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME I CAN PLEASE PERFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO -- TO TESTIFIED TODAY
I'M GOOD OR NOT BUT I'M NOT
SURE OF THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION IS AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN OVERSIGHT
AGENCY CHARGED WITH MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS
OF STATE GOVERNMENT IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE ISSUED THREE REPORTS
EXAMINING CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE
TO LABOR TRAFFICKING OUR
DECISION TO FOCUS ON LABOR
TRAFFICKING STEM FROM THE
FACT THAT EXISTING EFFORTS
TO COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON SEX
TRAFFICKING SO MANY EXPERTS
SUGGESTED LABOR TRAFFICKING
IS MORE PREVALENT WE BELIEVE
STRONGLY THAT EXISTING NUMBERS
AGAINST SEX TRAFFICKING MUST
CONTINUE BUT THERE MUST ALSO
BE AN INCREASED FOCUS ON
LABOR TRAFFICKING TRAGICALLY
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS FALL
PREY TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING EACH
YEAR INCLUDING HUNDREDS WHO
ARE EXPLOITED FOR THE VALUE OF
THEIR LABOR THE COMMISSION STUDY
CONCLUDED AT THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC UNLESS WE DON'T HAVE
DATA ON THE PANDEMIC'S IMPACT
ON TRAFFICKING RATES BUT WE DO
KNOW THE TRAFFICKERS TARGET THE
MOST VULNERABLE AMONG US WOULD
BE PROTECTED DAY MANY OF WHOM
ARE BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE
COLD NINETEEN PANDEMIC SH
NATIONAL DATA SUGGEST THAT THERE
IS NOT A SINGLE TYPE OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS TRAFFICKERS
PREY ON INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS
OF GENDER AGE OR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS AND RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT RUN AWAY FROM HOMELESS USE
AS WELL AS FOSTER CHILDREN ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO THIS
EXPLOITATION ONE STUDY OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AMONG HOMELESS YOUTH
AGE SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE IN
TEN CITIES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
AND OAKLAND FOUNDED EIGHT
PERCENT OF THE YOUTH HAD BEEN
VICTIMS OF LABOR TRAFFICKING
THESE TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTHS
WERE FORCED TO WORK IN FACTORIES
AGRICULTURE INTERNATIONAL DRUG
SMUGGLING COMMISSION BASED
SALES OR DOMESTIC SERVITUDE
SOME ALSO EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION LABOR TRAFFICKING
CAN BE DIFFICULT TO DETECT IT
CAN BE HIDDEN IN PLAIN SIGHT
OFTEN WITHIN BUSINESSES OR
INDUSTRIES THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
BE LEGITIMATE LABOR TRAFFICKING
IS AT TIMES CONFLATED WITH LABOR
EXPLOITATION WHICH BOTH OCCUR
ON A SPECTRUM OF THE PEWS AND OF
ALL THE PLAYERS WHO PROFIT FROM
THE ILLEGAL TREATMENT OF WORKERS
HOWEVER LABOR TRAFFICKING OCCURS
WHEN EMPLOYEES EXTERNAL LEVEL
OF CONTROL OVER THE WORKERS
AT LEAST AND TRACKED IN THE
SITUATION TO FIND AND PROSECUTE
LABOR TRAFFICKING AUTHORITIES
OFTEN NEED TO BE FAMILIAR WITH
THE UNDERLYING ELEMENTS OF
LABOR EXPLOITATION YEAH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE LARGELY
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
CONTEXT A LABOR TRAFFICKING
CRIMES THIS LACK OF TRAINING
MAY MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM
TO DISMISS LABOR TRAFFICKING
AS AN EMPLOYMENT PROBLEM AND
LAST WEEK IT HARDER TO UNCOVER
SHE TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS CAN
ACCESS HELP FROM A PATCHWORK
OF SERVICE PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE CALIFORNIA OFFERS
A NUMBER OF SUPPORT SERVICES
TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS
PRIMARILY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD IN ADDITION THERE ARE
TWENTY FIVE SERVICE PROVIDERS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO RECEIVE MONEY DIRECTLY FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TWENTY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
CUMULATIVELY FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIMS NOW
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF SERVICES AVAILABLE TO HELP
LABOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS THE
COMMISSION ALSO IDENTIFIED
A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES
THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
SURVIVORS ACCESS HELP NUMBER
ONE SURVIVORS NEED A RANGE OF
SUPPORT WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS
SAY WHICH PROGRAMS ARE MOST OF
OUR MOST AFFECTED AND HOW THEY
ARE BEST DELIVERED IN ADDITION
IT IS NOT ALWAYS EASY TO FIND
HELP THERE IS NO ONE STOP SHOP
TO FIND INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE STATEWIDE
NOW THE COMMISSION ALSO FOUND
TOO FEW TRAFFICKERS ARE HELD
FULLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ABUSES TRAFFICKERS FACE BOTH
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL ACTION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SANCTIONS FROM
A VARIETY OF LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL ENTITIES YET DESPITE
THE HUNDREDS OF KNOWN LABOR
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS TO SEEK
HELP EACH YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
LABOR TRAFFICKING CASES
THAT CAN BRING PERPETRATORS
TO JUSTICE REMAIN RARE
ON AVERAGE THERE ARE LESS THAN
THIRTY CONVICTIONS FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING EACH YEAR IN THE
STATE LESS THAN THIRTY LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS DIFFICULT TO
PROSECUTE FOR NUMBER REASONS
SURVIVORS MAY BE RELUCTANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN PROSECUTIONS
FOR EXAMPLE THEY MAY FEAR
DEPORTATION OR RETRIBUTION
INVESTIGATIONS ARE ESPECIALLY
COSTLY TIME CONSUMING AND
RESOURCE INTENSIVE REQUIRING
BALL SPECIALIZED INVESTIGATORS
OR RESEARCH NEW AREAS OF
LAW THE CRIME CAN OCCUR EVEN
WHEN THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF
PHYSICAL FORCE OR VIOLENCE
THIS CAN BE DIFFICULT TO PROVE
IMPORTANT WE DON'T USE SOCIAL
UNFORTUNATE ENOUGH IN EITHER
LOCAL OR STATE COURSE AT THE
STATE LEVEL DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING WAS
AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO PROSECUTE SINGLE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING COMPLAINTS BUT
THERE'VE BEEN NO PROSECUTIONS
TODAY THE LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY AND OTHER JURISDICTIONS
ARE EXPERIMENTING WITH USING
CIVIL ACTION TO GO AFTER
TRAFFICKERS THIS IS VERY
INNOVATIVE BUT AS A STATE WE
DON'T PRACTICE A LACK RESOURCES
LIKE PUBLISHED CASE LAW IN
TRAINING FOR PROSECUTORS TO
USE STATE LAWS TO PURSUE LABOR
TRAFFICKING CASES WE DON'T
HAVE FORMAL AND WILL USE OR
OTHER INFORMATION SHARING
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE TO FOSTER
ONGOING COORDINATION AMONG
RELEVANT AGENCIES THAT WE
HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
IN OUR REPORTS THE COMMISSION
OFFERED SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS
TO HELP CALIFORNIA PREVENT
TRAFFICKING HELP SURVIVORS AND
ALL TRAFFICKERS ACCOUNTABLE
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA SHOULD
FORM AN ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
COUNCIL TO COORDINATE EFFORTS
OF GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
NGOS AROUND FIGHTING ALL FORMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING STATE
PRIORITIZE SERVICES FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING SURVEYS SURVIVORS
INCLUDE THANK IN SERVICE
PROVISION TO LABOR TRAFFICKING
SURVIVOR SO WE CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS AND THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE POPULATION
RESEARCHING AND EVALUATING THE
EFFICACY OF SERVICE PROGRAMS
AND CREATING A USER FRIENDLY
DIRECTORY OF ALL RESOURCES
FOR TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO FIND HELP
LASTLY CALIFORNIA MUST ENHANCE
ITS EFFORTS TO PROSECUTE
TRAFFICKERS BY EMPOWERING MORE
STATE AGENCIES TO LOOK FOR
LABOR TRAFFICKING I THINK LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS WITH THE
TOOLS AND TRAINING THEY NEED TO
INVESTIGATE AND LITIGATE CASES I
IMPROVING COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AND
BY STUDYING OUTCOMES OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING CASES TO DETERMINE
THE BEST PRACTICES THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ONCE IMPLEMENTED
WILL STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO THIS HEINOUS CRIME
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER TESTIMONY
AND TO JOIN THOSE THAT ARE
ON THIS HEARING TODAY LOOKING
FOR SOLUTIONS FOR -- THIS THIS
PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS ALL THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN NOT ALLOWED WE WILL
NOW GO TO LEGALIZE FOR ABOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO COME AND SPEAK WITH YOU
ALL TODAY MY NAME'S LEE LAST
COUNT ON THE THIRTIETH RECTOR
OF SURVIVOR ADVOCACY OF THE
COALITION TO ABOLISH SLAVERY
AND TRAFFICKING IN LOS ANGELES
I SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER WORKING
ON THE FRONT LINES PROVIDING
CRISIS RESPONSE TO ESCAPING
SURVIVORS WELLS MENTORSHIP AND
SUPPORT SURVIVORS LEADERS OF
THE ANTI TRAFFICKING MOVEMENT
CASSOULET IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WITH A MISSION
TO ENSURE THAT HAVE THE KINGS
EDUCATION COMPREHENSIVE LIKE
TRANSFORMING SERVICES ADVOCACY
A GROUNDBREAKING POLICIES AND
SYSTEMIC CHANGE SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT WEEKS APART AT
THOUSANDS OF SURVIVORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN EMERGENCY SERVICES HOUSES
SHUFFLING AND HEALTH SERVICES
YOUTH PROGRAMMING ADVOCACY
EDUCATIONAL AND LEADERSHIP
TRAINING AND MENTORSHIP THROUGH
THESE PROGRAMS IF ANY HELPING
HAND HOW OUR SURVIVORS TO
BECOME LEADING VOICES SHAPING
POLICY AND PUBLIC WHERE IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED ON THE CALL
SEVERAL TIMES BUT WE WANT TO GO
IT IS CRITICAL THAT STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ADDRESSED
THE LACK OF RELIABLE DATA ON THE
PREVALENCE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHICH IMPACTS THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF EQUITABLE
POLICY AS WELL AS SERVICE
PROVISION FOR SURVIVORS WE
MUST ADDRESS THIS LACK OF DATA
BY PRIORITIZING AND INVESTING
IN PEER REVIEWED PUBLISHED
STUDIES ON TRAFFICKING BETTER
INFORMS BY SURVIVORS DURING
BOTH PLANNING AND EXECUTION
IT IS ALSO IMPERATIVE THAT
ANTI TRAFFICKING LEGISLATION
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS RECOGNIZE
THE HEIGHTENED RISK THAT BY
POCKET AND LGBTQ COMMUNITY
SPACE I CAN CONTRIBUTE TO HIGHER
VULNERABILITIES TRACKING WE NEED
TO THE U. S. NATIONAL COALITION
FOR HOMELESS HOMELESS LGBTQ
YOUTH ARE MUCH MORE VULNERABLE
TO SEXUAL EXPLOITATION AND
TRAFFICKING COMPARED TO OTHER
HOMELESS AND THEIR DATA THEY
FOUND THAT TWENTY PERCENT OF
HOMELESS YOUTH ARE LGBTQ IN THE
UNITED STATES AND FIFTY EIGHT
POINT SEVEN PERCENT OF THEM ARE
EXPLOITED FOR SEX TRAFFICKING
WHICH IS A MUCH HIGHER RATE
THAN THE THIRTY THREE POINT FOUR
PERCENT HETEROSEXUAL HOMELESS
YOUTH THAT ARE AT RISK OF SEX
TRAFFICKING HOWEVER ACCORDING
TO UCLA'S DATA THANK YOU
HOMELESS YOUTH ARE LARGELY UNDER
REPORTED AND UNDER IDENTIFIED
OUR SERVICES AND EXPERTS ADMIT
THAT AT THE ESTIMATE YOU KNOW
FORTY PERCENT MORE HOMELESS
YOUTH IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ
RIGHT NOW IN THE ANTI
TRAFFICKING WITHIN OUR
CURRENT APPROACH INCREASED
CRIMINALIZATION AND SURVEILLANCE
OF OUR COMMUNITIES HAS NOT ONLY
BEEN INEFFECTIVE AT PREVENTING
TRAFFICKING OFTEN HARMFUL TO
SURVIVORS CONDUCTED A SURVEY
MANY YEARS AGO OUR NATIONAL
SURVIVOR NETWORK WHERE OVER
NINETY PERCENT OF RESPONDENTS
REPORTED BEING ARRESTED AND
HALF OF THEM BELIEVE THAT THEIR
ARREST WAS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
TRAFFICKING AS A WIDESPREAD LACK
OF AWARENESS AND UNDERSTANDING
OF FORCED CRIMINALITY WHICH
OCCURS WHEN SURVIVORS ARE
FORCED BY THEIR TRAFFICKERS
TO COMMIT CRIMES ARE FORCED TO
ENGAGE AND CRIMINALIZED INDUSTRY
WE MUST INCREASE OUR EDUCATION
I'M FORCED CRIMINALITY AND ITS
IMPACT ON SURVIVORS ESPECIALLY
SURVIVORS OF COLOR TRAFFICKING
IS A CRIME THAT AFFECTS
SURVIVORS ALL IDENTITIES AGES
AND NATIONALITIES EIGHTY NINE
PERCENT OF CLIENTS -- I CAST ARE
BY TALK MEANING BLACK INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND CURRENT
CLIENTS WHO HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT
UNITIES ARE BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETED
AND IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM EVEN AFTER LEAVING
THEIR TRAFFICKING SITUATION
A CRIMINAL RECORD CAN STILL
FOLLOW IT IMPACT THE SERVICE
LIFE FOR ME EVERY OTHER ASPECT
OF IT IS REBUILDING INCLUDING
DISQUALIFICATION FROM PUBLIC
HOUSING WELFARE BENEFITS
JOB TRAINING EMPLOYMENT AND
IMMIGRATION RELIEF THE DENIAL
OF THESE BASIC NECESSITIES FOR
SURVIVAL CREATES THESE THAT CAN
RESULT IN RACE TRACK THESE
ARE JUST A FEW OF THE MANY
REASONS THAT WE MUST ADOPT
A HUMAN RIGHTS FRAMEWORK AND
ARCHITECTURE ASKING INITIATIVES
WHERE AIM SHOULD ALWAYS BE
TO INCREASE THE RIGHTS OF
SURVIVORS AND PROTECT THEM FROM
HARM WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM BY INVESTING IN NON
CRYSTALLINE REGIONS SERVICES
IT IS ALSO CRITICAL THAT WE
UTILIZED A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO DRESS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING REACTIVELY WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO ONLY SHOW UP FOR
SURVIVORS AFTER THE HARM TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WILL NEVER BE
ERADICATED IS WILL BE TO CREATE
A RECORD RESOURCES TO STRENGTHEN
OUR COMMUNITIES PROTECTING
OUR CHILDREN STARTS WITH
PROACTIVELY PROTECTING PARENTS
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS FREE
ACCESS TO HOUSING HEALTHCARE
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME AND STATE
IMMIGRATION HOW MANY ANTI
TRAFFICKING PREVENTION WE MUST
ENSURE THAT OUR POLICIES DO
NOT CAUSE HARM AND HARM
ANTI TRAFFICKING POLICY
REQUIRES ACTION ON SOCIOECONOMIC
INEQUITIES HOMELESSNESS RACIAL
DISPARITIES GENDER VIOLENCE
HOMOPHOBIA ABLEISM IMMIGRATION
ISSUES POLITICAL INSTABILITY
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISES AND MORE
ONE IN THREE PAST CLIENTS HAVE
SURVIVED LABOR TRAFFICKING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING MOVEMENT IN THE
UNITED STATES LARGELY OVERLOOKED
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
CHILDREN UNDER CURRENT FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE WORST DROUGHT IN COLLISION
IT'S NOT A NECESSARY COMPONENT
OF THE LABOR TRAFFICKING OF A
MINOR BUT WE DO NOT APPLY THE
SAME PRINCIPLE TO THE LABOR
TRAFFICKING EXCUSE ME THIS IS
NOT A NECESSARY COMPONENT IN
THE SEX TRAFFICKING OF MINORS
CURRENTLY COULD NOT APPLY THIS
PRINCIPLE TO LABOR TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS WHERE WE REQUIRED
BEFORE STRATA CORPORATIONS
SIMILARLY IT LAWS PROHIBITING
THE ARREST OF A TRAFFIC TO ENTER
ONLY APPLY TO SEX TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS LEADING LABOR
TRAFFICKING ESPECIALLY THOSE
AND CRIMINALIZED ECONOMY AT RISK
OF ARREST DEPORTATION SB SIX
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE PASSING
HARBOR CONDITIONS SURE ALL CHILD
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS TO ENSURE
ALL IMPACTED THESE RECEIVED
RESEARCH SAYS SHE SIXTY SIX
PERCENT CAST CLIENTS WHO ARE
FOREIGN NATIONALS WERE LABOR
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS TRYING
NONPARTISAN UNDOCUMENTED
SURVIVOR COMMUNITIES WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THEM THAT WE NEED
TO EXPEDITE ACCESS TO WORK
AUTHORIZATION IN IMMIGRATION
COURT TO ALLOW SURVIVORS TO
TRACK NINETY SEVEN PERCENT
ALL OF CALIFORNIANS ARE HOMELESS
TWENTY START ANY SERVICE WITH
US SURE MY CLIENT HAS TAKEN
UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PERCENT LONGER THAN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC DID INCREASED HOUSING
SOCIAL SUPPORT AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS WE'VE ALSO INCREASED OUR
SPENDING ON CLIENT NEEDS AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE UPWARDS
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PERCENT SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
IN FUNDING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SPECIFIC SERVICES IT IS NOT
ENOUGH SUPPORTING SURVIVORS
OF TRAFFICKING REQUIRES MUCH
MORE THAN SHORT TERM CRISIS
INTERVENTION FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO SUSTAIN LONG TERM
PROGRAMS THAT OUR COMMUNITY
LET LOW BARRIER AND GROUNDED
IN HARM REDUCTION PRINCIPLES
CALIFORNIA'S ENSURE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE CHILD CARE AND
EDUCATION ARE AVAILABLE TO ALL
MAGICALLY INCREASE EFFORTS TO
REFORM THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM
TO FOCUS ON SUPPORTING FAMILIES
ELIMINATE DISCRIMINATION REFORM
POLICING ENACT COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION WE MUST ENSURE
JUSTICE FOR ALL SURVIVORS TACKLE
THE ROOT CAUSES OF TRAFFICKING
GUARANTEED THE RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS ARE TRAFFICKED
PERSONS RESPECT INDIVIDUAL
PTOLEMY AND MITIGATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS THE ARREST
AND DEPORTATION AND DETENTION
WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR POLICIES
HOLISTICALLY CARE FOR SURVIVORS
AND ONLY THAT ITS TRAUMA
INFORMED EVIDENCE BASED AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY SURVEILLANCE
ON BEHALF OF CASTELLATED AND
AND THE SURVIVOR COMMUNITY I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INVITATION
TO SHARE EXPERTISE OUR EXPERTISE
AND TO OUR LARGER COMMUNITY WHO
IS HERE TODAY THIS LISTING FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOU SURVIVORS
AND WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
KATE WALKER BROWN SENIOR
DIRECTOR COLLABORATIVE
RESPONSES TO COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND MISSION TO
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
ARMS MY NAME IS KATE WALKER
BROWN A SHEER PROGRAMS AND
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
WEARING BEAT THE COLLABORATIVE
RESPONSES COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION INITIATIVE THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW HAS BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
AND WHICH USED FOR MORE THAN
FIFTY YEARS MY TEAM WORKS
TO ELIMINATE THE COMMERCIAL
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN
YOU BY DEVELOPING COLLABORATIVE
YOU CENTER RESPONSES TO SCORE
YOU CAN DAMAGE TO THE STATE
TO HEAL AND ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER
WITH COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE BOTH LARGE AND SMALL
BIGGEST LOS ANGELES AZULES WALL
STREET BENITO RURAL AND URBAN
RESOURCE REGION NOT TO TRANSPORT
AWAITING IDENTIFYING RESPOND
YOU THE IMPACT OF EXPLOITATION
IT MAKES TRIED REPORTING AND
IMPACT RIGHT EXPLICATION AND
YET STILL MUCH MUCH MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE OKAY TRYING SOME OF
THE KEY LESSONS LEARNED FROM
OUR WORK FIRST COLLABORATION
THE STATE AS YOU HEARD FROM
CHERYL AND OTHERS HAS RECOGNIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF COLLABORATION
THROUGH THE CREATION OF THE
STATE PROGRAM WHICH ENCOURAGES
THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY CROWD
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE FIVE
COUNTY ONGOING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT FAMILY WE HAVE
SEEN THIS COLLABORATION
WORKING COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOUNG PEOPLE
FEEL THE IMPACT OF THAT OF
THAT COLLABORATION WE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM USE THAT THEY
FEEL I THINK THE TEAM BEHIND
WORKING TOGETHER SO THAT
THEY'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
AND THE YOUNG PEOPLE ALSO --
ARE SEEN FOR WHO THEY ARE AND
NOT JUST THEIR EXPLOITATION
COLLABORATION IS ALSO SUPER
IMPORTANT AND THAT IT RECOGNIZES
THAT NOT ONE AGENCY OR OR
SINGLE AGENT PEAK TO ME I'VE
GOT A PERSONAL AND THAT THEY
NEED TO WORK ACROSS SYSTEMS
JUST AREN'T BEGUN PEOPLE
AND THAT FAMILY CAREGIVERS
THE SECOND COLLABORATION NEED
TO CONTINUE TO BE BUILT OUT TO
MAKE SURE THE INVOLVED COMMUNITY
BASED PARTNERS SO THAT WE DO
NOT OVER RELY ON PUBLIC SYSTEMS
WE NEED TO THINK CREATIVELY
ABOUT HOW TO SUPPORT YOUTH
AND FAMILIES WITHOUT HAVING TO
SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
FAMILIES EXAMPLE IF A YOUNG
PERSON AT RISK FOR EXPLOITATION
THAT PANELING OR NOT MOM OR
DAD MIGHT NEED SOME ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND COUNSELING RATHER
THAN SIMPLY CHOOSING TO FILE
ON THE FAMILY AND REMOVED
THE CHILD FROM THEIR CARE
-- WHAT WE'VE ALSO LEARNED FROM
THE COLLABORATION OF SOME OF
THE MOST IMPACTFUL SERVICES ARE
THE COMMUNITY BASED ADVOCATE
THEIR SEPARATE FROM PUBLIC
SYSTEMS BETTER WORKING TOGETHER
WITH PUBLIC FUNDS TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES AS WE REIMAGINE THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM FUNDING
AND CAPACITY BUILDING COMMUNITY
BASED GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION
MUST BE RIGHT OR TIES TO
-- AND ALSO FOR COLLABORATION
TO WORK EFFECTIVELY EVERYONE
NEEDS TO SHARE COLLECTIVE
MIND I MEAN WE ARE ENCOURAGING
ALL PARTNERS TO UTILIZE A
HARM REDUCTION APPROACH AS
WAS MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CAST ROACH PRIORITIZE
PRIORITIZE IS PROVIDING THE
YOU FOR THE INFORMATION AND
ACCESS TO SERVICES TO PROMOTE
LONG TERM STATE TAKE ALL
RECOGNIZING THAT THE YOUNG
PERSON TO GO MAY BE INVOLVED
IN EXPLAINED THE SITUATION
IT RECOGNIZES THAT ACT I GET
FROM EXPLOITATION OF NONLINEAR
NO MATTER WHERE YOU CAN
PORK FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU BECAUSE
RIGHT AWAY WE CAN INSURE IT
WE ENSURE THAT THEY WILL STILL
ACCESS MEDICAL CARE OR THAT THEY
KNOW WHO ON YOUR TEAM THEY CAN
CALL AND REACH OUT TO TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY FUNDS SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN MORE COMFORTABLE
UTILIZING THIS APPROACH ALL
SYSTEM COMMUNITY PARTNERS GET
NEED TO GET ON BOARD TO PROMOTE
THIS SORT OF LONG TERM CP
THIS REQUIRES FUNDING -- AND
AND WE AS AS CHERYL MENTIONED
PDFS IS PROMOTING GUIDANCE
AROUND THAT AND WE NEED OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AND COUNTY
AGENCIES TO ADOPT A COCKROACH
I ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS
AROUND CRIMINALISATION --
AS YOU NOTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WE UNLESS WE PROVIDE
THE SERVICES HE USED AND USEFUL
BECOME INVOLVED IN IT JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM FORTUNATELY WE NO
LONGER REST KID CAN CALIFORNIA
FOR PROSTITUTION AND WE'RE
MOVING TOWARDS MORE SERVICE
BIG MODEL THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE
CRIMINALIZATION HOWEVER KIDS
ARE STILL ENDING UP IN DETENTION
BOTH RELATED AND UNRELATED TO
THEIR EXPLOITATION WE MUST BUILD
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES
WHEN WE ARREST AND DETAIN WE
STILL HEAR THAT PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT THE ONLY WAY TO KEEP A
YOUNG PERSON OKAY BUT WE ARE
CLICKING TRAUMA ON THE YOUNG
PERSON AND SADDLING THEM WITH
A CRIMINAL RECORD CHECK WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEM FOR YEARS
TO COME UNLESS WE TRULY BUILD
OUT COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT
PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE TO LEAN
ON THE CRUTCHES INCARCERATION
WE WE INTERNATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOU PAUL ALONG WITH HER PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ARE LOOKING
WASTE ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS
WHO HAVE BEEN CRIMINALIZED
FOR THEIR SURVIVAL REGIONALLY
PASSED THE JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS ACT AND ARE LOOKING
TO EXPAND OUT IN COMING YEARS
WE ALSO MUST LISTEN TO SURVIVORS
OF MANY OF THE COUNTRY'S CENTERS
HAVE HAD MENTIONED WE'VE DONE
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
IN CALIFORNIA TO ENSURE THAT
SURVIVORS LIVED EXPERIENCE
EXPERTS CAN HELP SHAPE POLICY
IN PRACTICE TUESDAY THANK
ACTUAL HUMAN RIGHTS RECORD
THEY CAN'T TOUCH STRONGER PART
UP WE APPRECIATE YES THAT'S
OF LEADERSHIP AND BINDING
THAT'S WORK AND PRIORITIZING
INVOLVEMENT OF SURVIVORS MEET
EVERY ASPECT OF DEPARTMENTS
WORK BOTH IN THE WAY WORST
SURVIVOR IN THE LIVED EXPERIENCE
EXPERTISE COULD BE INVOLVED
EARLIER TO IDENTIFY CHALLENGES
DEVELOP SOLUTION CAN ACTUALLY
CARRY OUT THE SOLUTIONS WE HEAR
FROM KIDS ALL THE TIME THAT
THEY WANT STAFF MEMBERS FROM
CLINICIANS DOCTORS LAWYERS TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCES THE
BATTLE CARE BEST WAY TO DO THAT
IF THE HIGHER WITH EXPERIENCE
WORKING SURVIVORS INTO RUSSIA
BOB CAN DO THAT WE MUST REMOVE
SOME OF THE BARRIERS THAT
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE -- RELATED
TO EMPLOYMENT WHITE CRIMINAL
RECORDS -- AND WE ALSO
IN HIRING SIR SURVIVORS NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT ARE SO MUCH
MORE THAN THEIR EXPERIENCE AND
BRING A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
SKILLS SKILLS AND EXPERTISE
THAT NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED
YES WE ALL WE OBVIOUSLY NEED
TO BE LISTENING TO YOUNG PEOPLE
IT SEEMS OBVIOUS BUT IT'S NOT
ROUTINELY HAPPENING WE GET
RESERVE SEVERAL YEARS AGO IN L.
A. COUNTY TO LOOK AT CASE FILES
AND ALSO THEN TALKED TO YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
RELATED TO EXPLOITATION AND AN
INVOLVEMENT SHE WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A HUGE DISCREPANCY
AND WHAT THEY STAND FOR NURSING
AND I WHY DO YOU THINK ACTUALLY
IS TOO OFTEN WE FOCUS ON A
YOUNG PERSON'S BEHAVIOR WITHOUT
ASKING THE WHY BEHIND IT WE GET
FRUSTRATED THAT THERE IS A HOLE
IN THE WALL OR DO YOU JUST RUN
AWAY AGAIN WITHOUT RECOGNIZING
THAT MAYBE THEY LOST SOMEONE IN
YOUR LIFE OR IT COULD BE WORSE
ACTUALLY SOMETHING UNDER TWENTY
GRAND THESE ARE REAL EXAMPLES
EXPLICATION TAKES AWAY YOUNG
PERSON POINTING AGENCY PROVIDING
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN ON DECISIONS THAT AFFECT
THEIR LIVES CAN BE INCREDIBLY
HEALING AND CREDIBLY IMPORTANT
IT GIVES US INSIGHT INTO WHAT
THEIR HOPES AND DREAMS ARE
BEYOND FOCUSING EXCLUSIVELY
ON THEIR EXPLOITATION WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF BUILDING A
NEW FEEDBACK MECHANISM L. A.
COUNTY SO THAT YOUNG PEOPLE CAN
WEIGH IN ON THEIR CASE PLANNING
I'M SURE WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT SO THAT REAL TIME
CHANGES CAN BE MADE AND WE'RE
ALSO TRAIN SHOULD PACK POWER
BACK TO THE YOUNG PEOPLE SO
THAT THEY CAN ADVOCATE AT THE
SYSTEM LEVEL I'M TO MAKE CHANGES
BASED ON THE PROBLEMS THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING AS MENTIONED BY
OTHERS EXPLICATION CAN IMPACT
ALL YOU -- AND UP TO THIS POINT
-- KIND OF FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
GIRLS AND YOUNG WOMEN AS YOU
HEARD FROM THE EARLIER PANEL
AND WE'RE LEARNING MORE ABOUT
THE ENDPOINT IMPACT EXPLICATION
ON CERTAIN POPULATIONS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY BOYS
NATIVE YOUTH LGBTQ I A
AND THE SERVICE MUST BE
TAILORED TO THEIR INDIVIDUAL
IDENTITIES EXPERIENCE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR BOYS IT OFTEN TAKES
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE SHARING THAT
THEY EXPERIENCED EXPLOITATION
SO I KIND ONE MINUTE THERAPY
OPTION IS NOT GONNA WORK GREAT
IF YOU CAN'T CONNECTION TO
DIFFERENT CULTURAL IN HEALING
PRACTICES MAY BE TREMENDOUSLY
HELPFUL BUT OFTENTIMES THOSE
ARE RECOGNIZED AS HAVING AN
EVIDENCE BASED AND SO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO BE PAID FOR THREE
STATE FACT AND LAST
WEEK THE VALUE WEEK SERVICES
WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO TRY THINGS
OUT ON THE WEEKENDS WITHOUT
KNOWING THEY'RE MAKING THE
DESIRED IMPACT SO AS WE
TALKED ABOUT WE NEED A GOOD
BASELINE INFORMATION AND THEN
WE ACTUALLY NEED TO EVALUATE
SERVICES MMHM WE NEED TO ASK
AND LISTEN TO KIDS AND BASED
ON THAT INFORMATION WE HAD
SYSTEMS AND SERVICE PROVIDERS
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS
WE MUST CENTER SURVIVORS
ALL STATE IS THE POLICY AND
PRACTICE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
WE NEED TO IMPROVE I PARTY ALL
IDENTITIES PROGRAM BY PROVIDING
SERVICE BETWEEN EVERYONE
ASKING US ABOUT THE SERVICES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THE FINAL
PRESENTERS LESLEY STAR HI BOB
HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME IS LESLIE
HI MY BY USING HER PRONOUNCE
PRONOUNCE I'M A CO CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA THANK ACTION
TEAM WORKING ALONGSIDE KATE
BOB WALKER BROWN AND OTHERS
THAT YOU HEARD FROM TODAY
AND I'M ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S LIVES
THANK ACTION CAME IN THE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY BODY OKAY
COLDER'S PUBLIC SYSTEMS DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION CRITICS TANK
THAT EXPERTS CAN DIVERSE
PLACEMENT PROVIDERS AND
MARK FROM LEADERSHIP DOWN
TO FRONT LINE STAFF ORDERLY
AND OFFER ADDITIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES BETWEEN THE
QUARTERLY MEETINGS TO CHER
PROMISING PRACTICES IDENTIFY
CHALLENGES AND DEVELOP SOLUTIONS
TO BETTER SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THEIR FAMILIES WE DEVELOP
POLICY SOLUTIONS AND GUIDANCE
TO PROMOTE CONSISTENT APPROACHES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IMPORTANTLY
OUR WORK IS INFORMED BY OUR
SURVIVOR ADVISORY BOARD NEEDS
TO QUICKLY READ COME EARLIER IS
A NUMBER OF THAT ADVISORY BOARD
SHE WAS TESTIFYING I WAS TEXTING
MY COLLEAGUES SAYING WHEN
THERE'S MY TESTIMONY -- CAN'T
CODE OR ACTUALLY I'M GONNA GO
MUCH OF WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
HIM BUT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF I'M AN ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
I THINK SHE WAS ON POINT ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT ON FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN NINETY ANGEL DOES
AUTHOR PROVIDES MORE PRACTICE
WITH NICKELBACK PRESENTATION TO
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS ABOUT
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND MARK
ANGELA SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTY WITH OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
YOUNG CLIENTS WE ARE THE LARGEST
CHILDREN'S LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDER IN THE COUNTRY OUR
MULTI DISCIPLINARY STAFF INCLUDE
ATTORNEYS SOCIAL WORKERS MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND REYES
SPECIALISTS CASE MANAGERS PAYER
ADVOCATE AND SURVIVOR ADVOCATES
APPROXIMATELY TEN PERCENT OF
OUR TEN PERCENT OF OUR OVER
FIVE HUNDRED STAFF MEMBERS
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM PRIMARILY
AS FOSTER YOUTH BUT ALSO AS
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS POSTURE
AND THE DOCTOR CHELSEA
PROVIDES DIRECT REPRESENTATION
TO OVER FOUR HUNDRED CHILDREN
PERFECT COMMERCIAL SENSE
LIKE SEXUAL EXPLOITATION AT
ANY GIVEN TIME AND WE STOP
QUESTIONS THAT CHORDS AND VOCALS
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DEPENDING ON
THE CLIENT'S CURRENT SITUATION
ARE SPECIALIZED CARE TEAMS MADE
UP OF ATTORNEYS CASE MANAGERS
ARE SURVIVOR ADVOCATES ARE IN
DAILY OR WEEKLY CONTACT WITH
THEIR CHILD CLIENTS THEIR FAMILY
CARE GIVER AND THE TREATMENT
TEAM MY TESTIMONY TODAY IS
INFORMED BY THE EXPERIENCES OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR
CAMPAIGNS I LIKE TO START WITH
WHEN TALKING ABOUT P. C. R. FOR
A MOMENT TO CONTINUE TO KERRY
PARK ONE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE CCR WHAT
THE F. CARE GP EXCEPTION PERSON
TAKE AN EXPECTED INHERENT
GENIUS BECAUSE OF THE EXCEPTION
THAT HAS BECOME AS CHAIR
TEEPEES HAVE BECOME THE DEFAULT
PLACEMENT RATHER THAN BEING
RESERVED FOR USERNAME BENEFIT
COMING SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
PLACEMENT AND THEY ARE OFTEN
-- RELEGATED TO LIVING
IN AS YOUR TEAM PAINS FOR MUCH
LONGER THAN WHAT WAS ANTICIPATED
TO THE LEGISLATION AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY MOST TESTING OR
TNCS AND ESPECIALLY THE LARGER
INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS ARE NOT
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A LOVING
NURTURING PATIENT TRYING TO
INFORM THE INDIVIDUALIZED CARE
THESE CHILDREN NEED ONE SOLUTION
TO THIS SHORTAGE AND THIS COMES
IN THE FORM WHEN I'M SORRY
ONE SOLUTION TO THE SHORTAGE OF
FAMILY HOMES COMES IN THE FORM
OF A BUDGET ITEM CURRENTLY BEING
CHAMPIONED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
RUBIO AND OUR THIS ITEM IN
THE SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS WILL EXPAND
THE AVAILABILITY SPECIALIZED
FAMILY COMES FOR COMMERCIALLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED CHILDREN
THE FUNDING WILL BE TARGETED TO
ADDRESS THE SECURITY SHORTAGE OF
FAMILY BASED HOUSING INCLUDING
SUPPORTING RELATIVES WHO OFTEN
DO NOT RECEIVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF SUPPORT AS UNRELATED FOSTER
CARE GIVERS INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT YOU CAN
COUNT IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
-- JUST
ONE MOMENT I'M SORRY
DURING A TO SUPPORT YOUR
FAMILIES AND YOUR COMMUNITIES
AND CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE JOHN
INFORMED WAYS CDOS ENERGY ROOTED
IN AND UNDERSTAND THE COMMUNITY
ARE WELL POSITIONED TO MEET
THE CRITICAL NEED BUT CAN'T DO
THAT WITHOUT ADEQUATE PARKING
STREAMLINING SERVICES BEGINS
WITH RECOGNIZING THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN TRAFFICKED
MUST BE SEEN AN INDIVIDUAL'S
AND BURIED NEEDS THAT MAY NOW
WILL CHANGE FROM TIME TO TIME
AS THEY WORK IN THE TRYING
TO GAIN EXPERIENCE AND AS THE
AGING GROW THEY ARE NOT ONLY
ABLE AND THEIR CAPITAL WHERE WE
FOLLOW THE STRAIGHT LINE THERE'S
NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION
WE NEED TO PROVIDE A LIST OF
CLIENTS SPECIFIC SERVICES TO
CHILDREN WHEREVER THEY ARE AND
AND WHATEVER AND THAT THE GUY
WAS WHAT THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
SPECIFICALLY NUMBER ONE ACCESS
TO SUPPORTIVE SERVICES INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES CANNOT
BE CONNECTED TO ZIP CODES TYPE
OF PLACEMENT OR EAT OR EVEN
WHETHER OR NOT THE CHILD IS
RESIGNING APPROVED PLACEMENT
IN PLACE COULD GAIN PLACEMENT
MEETING AGENCY EXPECTATIONS
CANNOT BE A PREREQUISITE FOR
RECEIVING EDUCATION INITIAL
SUPPORT UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS
CURRENT TIME IN THE LAB AND
EXCHANGES AND THAT ALL OF THOSE
ITEMS ARE REQUIREMENTS WHENEVER
YOU IS OPEN TO MAKING ANY SORT
OF ENGAGEMENT THEIR TREATMENT
TEAM OUR TEAM HAS TO BE RAISED
TO SAY YES NOT TO FILL OUT A
FORM GET ONLINE WEEK PER SPACE
THIS MIGHT SOMETIMES NAME
PAYING FOR THE PROFESSIONALS
CAN SIMPLY BE AVAILABLE WHETHER
THE YOUNG PERSON SHOWS UP OR
NOT ENGAGING WITH THE CHILD
WHO'S BEEN VICTIMIZED CAN THEN
LET'S CALL WAYS IMAGINABLE
TAKES TIME PATIENCE CONSISTENCY
AND COMMITMENT ON THE ADULTS
IF YOU CONSIDER WHEN I WENT TO
A PRIVATE WHEN A PERSON IS IN
PRIVATE THERAPY WHEN THEY'RE
NOT THEY SHOW UP THERE ALL
THE TIME FOR THEM TO GET THEIR
NO SHOW THE PATIENT PAYS IN
OSHODI SOMETIMES IT'S CALLED
OFTENTIMES THE FACT THIS IS THE
TYPE OF FUNDING WE NEED TO MAKE
AVAILABLE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
FOSTER CARE WHO ARE WAITING FOR
OR IN MIND HER MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT BE TIED
TO THE CHILD MEANS AND CANNOT
START AND STOP BASED ON WHEN
THE CHILD LAST WINTER WHERE SHE
WILL NEXT I NEED TO FIND
SURVIVOR ADVOCATES PORTANTINO'S
AND THE CHILD AGENCIES SIMILAR
TO PARA PARTNERS AND CULTURAL
BROKERS AND THEN IT'S BACK FOR
ADVOCATES WILL HELP YOU FEEL
HEARD AND UNDERSTOOD A KEY
COMPONENT TO ACCEPTING SERVICES
ANIMAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE CHILDREN THERE SIR
WE NEED TO FIND NONTRADITIONAL
SERVICES IT WAS NOT READY FOR
THIRTEEN AND THEN INTEGRATE
SPORTS SCIENCE MUSIC ART
PROGRAM NOW I'D LIKE TO TOUCH
ON COLLABORATION TERM AS I
AS I WRAP UP MY COMMENTS I'D
LIKE TO ASK OKAY WALK AROUND
COMMENTS REGARDING YOUR VOICE
AND PARTICIPATION IN CASE
PLANNING AND DECISION MAKING
BUT ADDS THAT COLLABORATION IS
ONE OF THE LEADING THE YOUTH
THEIR FAMILIES AND ADVOCATES A
NUMBER OF CHANGES TRANSPARENCY
AND MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT
REQUIRED POWER SHARING AND
POWER SHARING IS EXTREMELY ARE
AND I EXPERIENCE POWER SHARING
IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR
GOVERNMENT -- MISTER BALL
EARLY ON IN THE HEARING SPOKE
ABOUT SHE ANY CHANGES WITH YOUR
CHILD AND FAMILY LEAD AND WHILE
THAT CONTACTED HIM TO
THE CHILD AND FAMILY LED THE
REALITY IS THAT THERE IS STILL
A SIGNIFICANT POWER IMBALANCE
THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT
FOR THE CHILD AND FAMILY TO
ALWAYS BE ACTORS PORTRAYED
AND OFTEN DOES NOT RESULT --
IN INVESTING THEY NEED BEING
PROVIDED BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR AGENCIES TO EITHER THEM
OR TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON EVERY
QUESTION THEY DON'T FIT WITHIN
ESTABLISHED AND TRADITIONAL
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS WHILE
SOME PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE AND THE
PATHS TO ACCESSING SERVICES AND
CONFUSING OVERLY COMPLICATED
SCHEME STEP MARKING GRAYSON
DOOR OPENERS UNLIKE THE NO
WRONG DOOR APPROACH CHILDREN
FAMILY ADVOCATES ANYTHING COUNTY
SOCIAL WORKERS OFTEN FIND THAT
EVERY DOORS LOCKED DOOR WHAT
IS PERHAPS MOST FRUSTRATING IS
THAT WHEN WE DO GO UP THE CHAIN
THERE IS AN ANSWER SERVICES
ARE IDENTIFIED PROVIDED FUNDED
EXTENT WHY IS THAT PRICE TRADING
BECAUSE IT TAKE THERE ARE
STILL MANY HURDLES TO GET THERE
BECAUSE OVERWHELMING BECAUSE IT
TAKES SO LONG TO RESOLVE THESE
BARRIERS THAT WE OFTEN END UP
BACK AT STEP ONE BECAUSE NEWS
HAS CHANGED PLACEMENT OR THEIR
NAMES HAVE CHANGED SO INCOME
I WOULD PAYMENT STREAMLINING
SERVICES -- WELL BEING WHY ON
REMOVING MANY OF THESE BARRIERS
OPEN COMMUNICATION WHERE ALL
OF THE AVAILABLE AND SERVICES
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL OF THE
AVAILABLE SERVICES IS RANDY
AVAILABLE TO ANY MEMBER OF THE
CHILD'S TEAM HELD UP BY ONE
PARTICULAR GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
I'M PLEASE FEEL WE'RE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL COMMENT
IF YOUR STAFF HAS QUESTIONS
THANK YOU LESLIE HI MOM AND I DO
WANT TO -- IT WOULD BE GREAT
TO HEAR FROM ALL THE PRESENTERS
NOT JUST LIMITED TO THIS PANEL
BUT TO ALL PRESENTERS -- PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE IT WOULD BE GREAT TO
HEAR WHAT THE LEGISLATURE --
AND AND SOME DIDN'T MAKE --
CHAIRMAN -- GERMAN NOVEL MADE
SOME SUGGESTIONS OTHERS HAVE
ALSO MADE SOME SUGGESTIONS
AS WELL BUT IT WOULD BE GREAT
TO HEAR WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DO TO ASSIST SURVIVORS OF
TRAFFICKING AND IN COMBINATION
WITH THAT WHAT WAYS CAN WE
CREATE A STATE WIDE COORDINATED
-- RESPONSE AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE I AM OFFERING AB
TWO FIVE FIVE THREE IT'S --
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BILL THAT
ADDRESSES MULTI DISCIPLINARY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING COUNCIL THE
CREATION OF THAT COUNCIL WHICH
-- IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA'S PROVEN TO BE BEHIND
ON AS FAR AS A DEVELOPMENT THAT
COUNCIL SO BRING IN THAT TO --
BRINGING THAT TO FRUITION IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME -- BASED
ON SOME COMMENTS THAT CAME
FROM THIS PARTICULAR PANEL IT
JUST MAKES ONE WONDER HOW
MUCH OF THIS CRISIS COULD BE
AVOIDED BY JUST TAKING TIME TO
LISTEN TO YOUNG VOICES PRIOR
TO THE TRAUMA THAT EXPLOIT --
THAT EXPLOITATION IN KERR'S
AND JUST -- WE TALK ABOUT
RESPONDING TO SURVIVOR OR
RESPONDING TO VICTIMS WE TALK
ABOUT TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
RESTORATION AND JUSTICE AND
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS BUT --
AS AS IT GOES BACK TO THAT OLD
SAYING AN OUNCE OF PREVENTION
IS BETTER THAN A POUND OF CURE
AND REALLY IT'S INCUMBENT ON
OUR SOCIETY IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
ALL OF US AS A COMMUNITY TO
STOP SLOW DOWN PAY ATTENTION
TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND LISTEN
AND THAT NOT SO MUCH DICTATE OR
OR ALWAYS JUST ADDRESS THE BAD
OR ADVERSE BEHAVIOR BUT MAYBE
THERE'S A CAUSE OR REASON TO
THAT BAD OR ADVERSE BEHAVIOR
AND TO GET DOWN TO THE ROOT
OF IT AND ACTUALLY LISTEN TO
THEIR VOICES AS LEGITIMATE
VOICES AS VOICES THAT MATTER
AND THEN THE POWER SHARING
PART OF THAT GOVERNMENT ISN'T
REALLY GOOD AT AND -- BUT
MAYBE THE COMMUNITY CAN BE AND
-- THE COMMUNITY CAN STAND UP
AND BE THE ADVOCATE FOR THAT
VOICE PRIOR TO EXPLOITATION
-- IN MANY MANY CASES WITH THAT
I DO WANT TO THANK SHERMAN --
NAVA AND ALSO LEAD LEISURE PAL
MS BROWN AND MS HI MOM FOR YOUR
REALLY INCREDIBLE WORK AND THE
ADVOCACY THAT YOU'RE DOING AS
WELL AS THE POWERFUL TESTIMONY
THAT YOU PROVIDED TO DATE I
DO WANT TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT -- ANYONE IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE TABLE OVER
HERE AND WE WILL LIMIT YOU TO
JUST A COUPLE OF MINUTES PER
PERSON AND SEEING NO MOVEMENT
AT ALL -- AT THIS TIME I
WOULD THEN LIKE TO THANK ALL OF
THE PANELISTS -- FOR THEIR TIME
AND FOR THEIR TESTIMONY THIS IS
TRULY AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
DEMANDS REFLECTION IN CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW OUR CURRENT
LAWS AND THE SERVICES WORK
TO ASSIST CHILD TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS AGAIN I DO WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR INPUT
AND PARTICIPATION I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON SOLUTIONS
TO THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED
HERE TODAY AND TO GET THE MUCH
NEEDED FEEDBACK FROM ALL OF
THE PRESENTERS ON EVERY PANEL
WITH THAT -- THIS SPECIAL
HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU